foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
resignation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just block yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in wait
until next time is now
she has methodically done what he needed
to do to get another shot at the title
the pressure to seize the moment this
time rests heavily upon him and Jana
palmistry once again holds a one-point
lead in the 2023 world championship
match what an incredible bounce back
dingley Wren knows firsthand what the
end of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame Don is just gonna
smash through on the king side I think
didn't have a good day this is all over
and what a game I have to say
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
foreign
World Championship 2023 is currently
taking place between janaponishi and
ding lyron score is currently three two
one three two sorry in neponishi's favor
after some traumatic roller coaster
chess and today to cover all the action
I'm Grandmaster David Hull and with me
is my good friend and colleague Anish
giri world number six Anish you've been
here the whole way I hope you've been
fighting the match so far
thank you Dave it's been a pleasure to
follow the match lots of ups and downs
and today we are at a important juncture
as young has taken the lead again
and ding having the white pieces has an
opportunity to come back make it a 3-3
looking forward to see this game
yes today will be game six historically
a very important game in any match and
let's have a recap of how we got here
and uh being Lauren of course struggling
at the early stages of the match game
one was a draw but game two Yan the
promise was the one who struck first
being far from his best surprised us
with an early opening idea which
backfired game three he steady the ship
it was a draw and in game four ding
struck back with a very impressive win
with the white pieces yesterday Anish
the roller coaster continued this
topsy-turvy match game five talk us
through what happened
yes that was a special game Jan has
brought something to the table he played
his comfortable 184 his Spanish that and
small opening Advantage was really
deeply prepared played everything very
quickly ding was on the back foot didn't
find the best defensive setup
Jan just kept upping the pressure and
without any major blunders just
continuously being under pressure making
a few inaccuracies he eventually was the
game and had to resign was a masterpiece
to be honest
yeah Masterpiece indeed and that does
take us to today ding will have white
again will be wanting to strike back but
of course we're just watching from home
out in Astana we have chess updates and
weather reports from Mike Klein himself
thanks guys what a match we've already
had three out of the five games have
been decisive that's sometimes more than
we get in an entire match before we talk
about the game today though let's talk
about the weather many questions were
asked about it at the press conference
napometershi did take his customary walk
despite the fact that it's negative 19
Celsius wind chill outside he bundled up
put on a lot more clothes and did his
thing he is Russian after all but yeah
the weather is taking a bit of a
Benjamin Button effect we were in
t-shirts outside not only a few days ago
and already now we're back to wearing
winter coats we've gone from spring back
to Winter I can't really understand it
in fact it did affect gameplay a little
bit although Napoleon she said it's not
like a sporting event but an apometry
could be seen circling around the board
a little bit doing a lot of pacing and
he said he did that just to stay warm as
far as the game ding said that this loss
was more painful than his one a few days
ago one of the nice things about this
match from a player perspective is that
we know that a one game Advantage is not
necessarily enough to hold up like in
some previous matches there seems to be
no indication that the players are going
to play more conservatively just because
they have one win in the pocket ding has
already come back from a one-game
deficit once we will see if he can
strike back right away and continue the
string of decisive games for chess.com
this is Mike and Austin on now back to
you guys
these are the head-to-head scores
between dingleren and Jan napomnishi
after Yan's Victory yesterday he does
lead in classical chess five wins to
three still a small margin still more
than half the match to go and uh Anisha
it was interesting to hear Mike say that
uh ding found yesterday's defeaton even
more heartbreaking than game two what
are your thoughts is he going to be able
to strike back today
yes indeed and I can understand where
ding was coming from it felt like a nice
Redemption story for him as the start
was really really tough he seemed very
nervous at the visibly he was spending a
lot of time in the rest area was making
lots of weird most weird decisions that
are anchors for player as good as Ding
and it seemed like everything was
turning around his game three was good
game four was even better he won the
score was even Jan looks shaky and he
was very optimistic thing but suddenly
the trend shifted back again and he lost
the game and he felt that everything was
fine and he said that was a devastating
feeling and I understand where he's
coming from that said he has come back
uh before and he wants will want to come
back once again I don't think he he will
despair even if not today there's still
plenty of opportunities in the match
it's a long long match
uh though of course it's not endless so
you do want to strike back at some point
and you definitely don't want to let it
get get away from you as a two-point
lead for Jan would already be a very
significant advantage
and I've been doing my research in each
game six it's been uh very important
historically I I estimate there have
been 18 decisive games in World
Championship matches in game six which
is an incredible ratio almost half of
world championship matches that's been a
decisive game in this round of course
people remember 2021 uh Magnus Carlson
against Jana ponichi the longest game in
world championship history they've been
blunders between Anna and Carson game
six it always seems to be this game uh
so I'm hoping I'm predicting that there
will be even more drama uh as uh yeah as
we are waiting for the players to walk
in should we make last minute
predictions for this one this round
yeah I think I can sort of give a
prediction of what I expect will happen
on a for more more General basis I think
ding will go for something where a lot
of pieces will remain on the board where
structure might be a little bit closed
and um where there will be no direct
trades in the center but in terms of a
concrete opening a concrete first move
that's pretty hard he might do one C4
again he might try to do something
similar maybe already with Knight F3 G3
and opening you are familiar with it's
hard hard to say maybe I would say
probably
um no E4 I think and D4 is possible with
the name so with some sort of a name so
maybe but really hard to say what are
your thoughts yeah he stole the words
out of my mouth I would love to see the
ready uh it's my old man repertoire
where there's minimal Theory you get an
original creative game very early on but
of course Yan will have prepared for
that he's got a bulletproof repertoire
at this point
um I'm predicting a decisive result
either way I think the ding is going to
take big risks in this game uh I just
have a feeling from his mindset from the
way we've seen the match develop so far
and uh
I'm not gonna make any predictions
either way because I think it could go
either way at this point that's the one
thing the match has shown us but
meanwhile we do see Yan arriving at the
board the first to arrive and uh ding we
saw a few moments ago in his rest area
uh yeah game six I will predict yeah
already just because I'm loyal to my
favorite openings
okay okay no it's fair enough fair
enough and Jan is back with the same
suit as he were yesterday the lucky suit
for him I think looks so I like the I
like the way it looks on him I'll try
one on like that as well though I think
it really depends on you know on your
face color as well how you match with
the suit but uh really liking the you
know young looks very fresh last couple
of days and
yeah wondering in terms of um from a
game theory perspective uh how much risk
should ding actually take and we have to
analyze that I'm not sure how to do this
kind of analysis but I am not sure
intuitively I I feel that taking a lot
of risks today could backfire because a
loss would be devastating a draw would
not be the end of the world but knowing
Ding and seeing the way he played so far
I think he will take a lot of risks and
so I do think it will be a three result
game I think Jan very likely will get
chances of his own as well and I think
anything can happen uh dink so far is
played very aggressive even with the
black pieces that game after he lost the
previous one in round two the game three
if you remember well with the black
pieces
oh he uh I believe he accommodated
actually with us that day as well and
he was uh very very aggressive very
pushy there so well we'll see what what
will happen today I I think the loss for
another loss for ding is not out of the
question and that that would be really
bad news
yeah it would be uh almost disastrous
footing losing another white uh if he
does take risks if they do backfire
um like you say kind of game management
match management Game Theory I'm not
sure it's going through their mindset
Ding and Richard report when they're I
mean it's not in their style really to
make those kinds of uh calculations I
think they both just want to just get
out there play a game and meanwhile
doing interestingly still sitting in his
rest area reluctant to come to the board
what do you make of that Anish uh Jan
looks ready looks primed to go
well I heard yesterday was sort of a
cold there we had our you know
cheers.com weather report that we are
branching out as you know it's a it's a
company and we're also doing weather
management but um I heard that they they
tried to make it a little warmer in the
playing Hall today so perhaps the
resting area is also a little bit warmer
so maybe the players will be able to
spend some time ding also looking
dashing with this with the suit as well
I have to say uh players looking very
sharp today ready for for battle
nice blue suit there for Ding and uh
well both seem uh very much ready for
game six as it starts in just six
minutes as well
I like it dashing ding ready to kill
with the white pieces and uh he's going
to be adjusting the moves uh dressing
the pieces sorry and the first
ceremonial move will be made in just a
few moments time
um yeah the ready the English it could
be anything at this point but ding I'm
liking the fact that he has been sitting
at the board the last few games
yesterday didn't go his way of course
kind of got caught out in the opening
and that's why I think his strategy will
be to remain flexible
take the game into unknown Waters as
early as possible and uh you must be
impressed by Yan right just the way he
bounced back I I know I was here in game
four we made those predictions just
before the rest day that Yan would
struggle psychologically after his
defeat he came back with a very
impressive win now it's up to dink to
show that he's got that metal again
yeah he says I think Jan made a very
good call yesterday I mean in hindsight
certainly he did he played this uh one
of the main
you know main things in his repertoire
are Spanish and he did nothing weird put
spawn on D3 c3a for all the standard
moves you know no no unnatural play
there everything was very clean and
clear-cut then he started fighting for
the only big Square on D5 then you know
the game sort of uh played itself in a
sense I'm not to take any credits away
from Jan and certainly his conversion
was very impressive at some point he
took some very strong decisions but in a
way um
I think he was fortunate to an extent
that he was able to
um to bounce back immediately and got
these opportunities and well he did
everything right it's always how it
works in Chelsea you cannot force a win
you always need a mistake or a bad
decision from the opponent but if you do
everything right well the mistakes are
gonna comment yeah he did his job in the
previous game now the task is cut out
for ding so far I feel I don't know if
I'm being subjective here but I feel as
thoughyan is a little bit better
prepared in the opening
cannot quite pinpoint as to why but
somehow his ideas with the white pieces
they're just they feel a little bit more
poisonous to me it feels like he puts a
little bit more pressure than ding does
ding is just much more trying to Simply
get any sort of game any kind of
position without
um you know without fighting for much
Advantage yeah I'm still trying to fight
for some sort of an advantage I feel and
is able to do that in his white games so
I I don't know I think it'll be harder
for ding to make something happen today
but as we had seen in his previous white
game things definitely can
um can you know it can take shape for
him and yeah the players are uh you know
having these last three minutes before
the game the most nerve-wracking ones
the ones where you cannot leave the
board anymore but you also cannot make a
move and you are stuck in this limbo
fortunately it only lasts three minutes
you're gonna get out of it very soon
yeah they will be allowed to start the
clocks very shortly and Anish you
mentioned that you feel Jan is better
prepared do you think this is just a
kind of Prior experience he's been here
he's done it before 2021 okay that
didn't go so well but uh he's been in
that zone he knows what it takes and
ding with his second report do you think
it's a bit of inexperience on that part
I would have criticized link by no means
I just felt that Jan's prep was even
more poisonous but I I think uh indeed
when you prepare for world championship
match and for the candidates and you do
that with a large group of people of
people then you're prep it sort of
accumulates your knowledge it
accumulates and I think Jana in the past
few years he's been able to accumulate a
lot of knowledge and I know Jan for many
years and I think there were times when
he was much less prepared but due to
this recent uh events these matches and
the candidates tournaments he definitely
built up a huge prep and we have the
first move played by Dana resin it's a
fide
um
I think vice president I believe she is
and a big part of video and uh did you
see what Mushi made
uh it looked like one C4 it was a pawn
push that's all I could see
um yeah done a very strong Latvian chess
player and uh politician I believe
Deputy chair of the video management
board and
um yeah either way doing seemed to take
her move back and keeping us guessing
he's played a couple of different first
moves with white already in this match
one D4 and one C4 will he switched
things up even further uh Moment of
Truth any second now the clocks will be
started I'm predicting one Knight F3 a
niche you seem to be saying one D4 or C4
again but I think one C4 I think I think
the the move uh Dana who is a very
strong player indeed as you mentioned
made I think that was ding's suggestions
and I think one C4 has already been
maybe predetermined but maybe I'm wrong
he can indeed take it back still it is
allowed to take one move back if you
have a guest coming no no more after
that but the first one you can take back
very often but I do think that one C4 is
what he asked her to play I think that
there's more ding style he's you know uh
he's sort of an extremely honest person
so he has a habit of just
saying um yeah he's just being honest
even when you don't need to be honest
let's let him put it this way so I
expect one C4 and we're off we have the
handshake and okay it is D4
well then I misread that uh D4
interesting yes I predicted the name so
if it will be a D4 but oh no not at all
wow Knight F3 move to staying flexible
um this one does cut out yeah cuts out
the NIMS are at least Danish but I guess
surely he's not going for the London
system or any other things associated to
Knight F3
yes he does yes oh no oh no oh no the
London okay I think half of the
viewership has already lost
um out of protest a lot of viewers you
know have logged out of our broadcast
everybody hates the London but well well
let's let's wait and see I think Dean
and Richard they have prepared something
there there London you know it's it's
become bigger than before it was before
it was just a scheme where you just make
all these moves like you just bring a
pawn here here nice here Bishop here on
here a castle and you chill but now
there's lots of concrete Theory
and um
it's much more subtle than that
sometimes you develop the bishop to E2
sometimes to B5 sometimes you take dc5
sometimes you postpone C3 sometimes you
you don't go H3 you go H4 like all sorts
of or sometimes in early 95 a lot of
subtleties there so a lot of theory now
and London is no longer the same no
longer where it used to be
um but a very exciting uh choice of
opening
um well in in some sense I feel maybe my
prediction is still not too much off as
I suggested something where a lot of
pieces will remain on the board and
London is one such opening position is
also likely quite closed
yeah go ahead I was good sorry I was
just going to say that Ding felt so
guilty playing the London system he left
the stage temporarily but he's back and
we do see some forcing moves uh to me
this is like the Italian game of 1d4
it's just so many move orders nuances as
you mentioned but there are some forcing
lines and it looks like Yan playing very
quickly he has obviously prepared for
this I'll mention Magnus Carlson plays
this quite a lot and uh Jan was prepared
for him in 2021
so surely he would have done some work
with cianally Trader pawns on D4
have you seen Yan face the London system
that much I'm trying to recall uh I
haven't an ish well I've played it
against him myself
um so I know that for a fact I've played
it against him
in this online
um tour I think a season ago or a season
or two ago that the first season of the
tours 2021 I think we speak and I think
my logic was that Jan used to be a
Greenfield player
and so as a Greenfield player you never
faced London
um
when the opponent is out on G6 so I
thought it might be smart to play the
land against him since he was just
starting build starting to build his
repertoire
and I think at the time indeed his
London was a little bit more shaky in
the London also he has always been going
for the E6 Bishop D6 setup by the way
always this is 56 setup but now he went
for something entirely different and as
you mentioned Magnus Carlson plays
London a lot and very successfully too
so Jan must have spent a lot of time
preparing for London for his match
against Magnus and now he seems to be
able to use that prep in this match CD
Bishop F5 that's a relatively rare
system
um there are much more fashionable uh
Trends here with Queen B6 is a huge one
where you take on B2 later on Knight H5
uh is also a very very trendy system
five it's uh
it's it's a thing as well a very natural
uh way to play you take and develop the
bishop but uh
that there is quite quite some Theory
here but it's a little bit less known I
think Bishop B5 is how it goes and then
Queen comes to B6 very often you go C4
and it gets complicated and I think at
the end of this complications actually
black does have a very solid position so
I think I understand what Jan is trying
to go for but ding is thinking he can
also play it differently than Mission B5
he can just play it just finish
development with C3 but then black has a
comfortable position he'll go e626
castleland finish development
yeah actually uh this system with Bishop
F5 recently I was looking for a very
young student and uh the student wanted
another repertoire where it required
almost zero Theory almost zero knowledge
where you could just get a position and
play as black against the London system
and I recommended this one because yes
why can't play Bishop B5 and maybe some
direct lines but uh I think majority of
London system players will just develop
pieces and ding has that dilemma now if
he doesn't go Bishop B5 if he just plays
like C3 uh as you say an issue it's
going to become a very long uh
maneuvering game and uh we should also
remind the viewers of the time control
they do have two hours for 40 moves no
increment they do gain 60 minutes after
move 40 and it's only after move 60.
they gained 15 minutes and a 30 second
bonus and maybe Jan is going for one of
those long games we know in 2021 he had
I think it was seven and a half hours
against Magnus cars in multiple time
controls uh okay dink does go C3 so
avoiding any direct kind of conflict
here and like you say E6 is coming
Bishop D6 is coming not much white can
do about that now
um I've got to say I quite like these um
these types of positions for both sides
just in Practical terms the Carl's bad
but uh is the Carlsbad the car's good
here and if we know that they had this
uh they had this Pawn structure against
each other back in game three
yeah I think
um colors reversed but basically
basically no reverse so like that if you
know what I mean like the colors have
reversed but so did the players so they
are still on the same side of the Carl's
bus
yeah the kalva structure is the
referring to these two pawns against
these two Pawns
usually with this uh attached to them as
well and then we spoke about this
minority attack plan I mean very long
term of course not early first finish
development prepared five or there is
this F6 E5 F3 E4 but with the Knight
already on F6 they usually it's the
minority attack that you do but you can
also sometimes you can also go for the
E5 break and try to hold that position
with an isolated Pawn
especially with black you can you can
often do that
yeah David so you mentioned a student
that wants to know little Theory and
just get a playable position you're
talking about Marcus Carlson here or
somebody else
no comment Anish no it's someone a few
hundred points lower rated than Magnus
Castle okay just to clarify just to
clarify you know what is a big thing by
the way is this um so Queen B3 is a very
tempting move
and then there you surely are aware of
the spawn sacrifice Bishop the six can
be seven Bishop takes F4 yeah
yeah maybe we can show this on the board
because uh if ding is feeling ambitious
then this is one of the few
direct attempts you can go for otherwise
it is purely maneuvering I think and
uh here we do see uh Queen b3anish talk
us through this line because Bishop D6 I
guess it's only come to light in the
last few years it's been spotted by
engines and so on yeah I must say it's
not like I have too much to say in this
position uh well I don't like it's not
like I have pages of the analysis here
that I I would share but um
I think it's a it's a trendy thing and I
I think in some of the versions
it sometimes the bishop is on G4
sometimes on H5 sometimes on F5
and depending on where that Bishop is
some of these positions are very good
for black some of them are not as good
for black it's very concrete so black
has the bishop pair the White Queen is a
little bit misplaced and the black king
although it looks like it's uh sort of
in trouble as it hasn't castled it will
actually find a very safe place on G7
after G6 or G5 and King G7
so the big question is if uh White will
be able to finish development bishopy to
Castle and then protect the B2 Pawn as
well somehow after potential repeat and
if white will be able to consolidate
this position up a pawn but certainly
some compensation for um
or black and it's very very concrete I
mean some computer analysis are required
here I I don't know if anything will
take this direction I think
yeah honestly I'm not sure it will be
very unpleasant for for him if he's not
as well prepared as young because the
problem with the London system and uh
it's you know it's one of the decent uh
one of the good openings
but the problem with the London system
is that black has so many different
systems to choose from and I've had that
issue myself with the white pieces when
I played the London very often even
though you prepare you are the one who
is choosing the opening so you chose the
London but then it's so hard to guess
what black will play there are like 10
systems that equalize and five more that
are maybe very slightly worse but you
have to know what you're doing and so
even if you you know you're gonna play
the London and you spend the entire day
uh preparing for it
you still might be less prepared than
your opponent who will actually choose
one of the one of these 15 lines and we
might see the situation here ding sort
of chose the London but he is the one
who is less prepared for this game and I
think that's what happens and one of the
reasons why London is still not as
popular as it could be that just has a
lot of choice and this is just one of
the many many lines
and we see on the camera ding not really
showing positive body language right now
either he's asking himself you know why
didn't I check this exact line and you
say a niche there's so much to prepare
for why didn't I check the specific move
order
um or he's just on his own and
yeah either way it can be unpleasant I
don't know about you and each but I find
myself so many times around move 10 15
just sitting there beating myself up in
my head just saying okay I could have
checked this I could refresh this
recently but instead it's uh just that
really unpleasant decision do you play
into your opponent's preparation and
risk even more with the white pieces or
do you just play on and admit you have
no advantage in a quiet maneuvering
system what do you think uh it's going
through ding's mind yeah I think his
body language suggests that he might be
intended Queen B3 but now realize that
he doesn't want to dare
um or or sometimes you know if you read
too much into body language or colleague
Daniel always likes to say he doesn't
like to read too much into body language
and it is it is true well you can indeed
if you want to do it you can just finish
your development
but the question is then well how
ambitious are you let's say Bishop E2
probably Bishop comes to D6 you can
trade you can Castle
and then you have you have various ways
of playing this you can try to go after
this bishop Maybe
though trading the bishop for a night is
not going to yield you that much
you could also just not trade that
Bishop uh I think the other move that
comes to mind is Bishop B5 where you
apply a bit of pressure on the Knights
of potentially you control the square a
little bit better but it's all um yeah
it's all not so not so much and uh I
think he has a big Choice here um it
could be three or or not can be three
but
I I think ding should be in his spread
but he looks really pissed I did he
could he have already mixed up here that
he should have played Bishop B5 and he
plays C3 and now he's upset like why why
is his body language so negative
yeah it's it's really hard to get a call
on uh ding Lauren's body language right
now um I think he might be right either
he's mixed something up or he's annoyed
at himself that he hasn't looked at
Queen B3 and this whole line uh kind of
in the recent uh in the recent past
if you're going to go for this queen B3
is white and go Pawn hunting then you
want to have looked at this uh in the
last few days you want to be fully aware
of all those nuances like you said later
inish because actually our position
of the two Bishops and the misplaced
black king it's very dangerous for white
uh as far as I can recall you can uh
certainly find yourself in big trouble
if you don't know all the details so
um yeah it just feels like he's kind of
stuck in his head a bit too much we know
that dings had this emotional kind of
Journey so far in the match and he's
kind of uh
internalizing everything right now maybe
having flashbacks to earlier points in
the match where he could have gone a bit
deeper with his preparation
and uh I've got to ask as well we
mentioned the Carlsbad poor structure
ding had this uh structure with the
black pieces in game three it seemed to
me that he maneuvered quite well okay he
complete he plays a move looks like
Bishop to B5 there we go but this Pawn
structure he seems to like this
structure and Yan has been consistently
going for the black side which side
would you take if you had a choice or
say that we get a maneuvering position
let's go existential here yeah you're
calling me out there uh I think
there are
there are mainly two types of players
and there are those who like them with
either color and there are those who
don't like them with either color
foreign
which side um
I think it depends on who I play it's
one of these positions where if you feel
you are superior in this lower game
I'd certainly take it uh if I play a
very strong player
well let's say one of the world's top
like Carlson or Ding and then I would
really try to make sure I have a good
position
so I wouldn't want some dodgy calls but
but of course if I play a player
significantly or lower rated then I have
a dodgy cars but I can imagine that I'll
be quite happy because you have a lot of
display I think from body language of
ding by the way he mixed something up
for sure because I think C3 and Bishop
B5 it's really not a thing
there is a variation here where you go
A6 and then C3 Bishop of five
and after bishopper 5 directly like
you're supposed to fight for the
advantage with Bishop B5
but yeah I don't know C3 Bishop B5
combined with his uh facial expressions
sort of make me feel like he's uh yeah
something has gone slightly wrong with
his breath but that said uh the damage
is extremely limited because well it's
even better sometimes you know because
Jan is so well prepared it's even better
to mix something up do something
non-princeable because if you do
something principled after Bishop B5 on
move seven the line goes like Queen b64
and it gets very forced and then likely
Jan will be completely prepared and
equalized by force while here Jan is uh
confused he will be confused and we will
get a game and uh well we saw in the
previous Carlsbad game that Ding was
maneuvering a little bit more a little
bit more accurately with a little bit
more feel if you'd agree with me and
then
if if we look at its from another sort
of a more Global sense then yes a thing
might be not too unhappy with the fact
that they got this position at the same
time uh having the black pieces Jan of
course was worried about something some
prep in the opening there would be
something uh danger somewhere a pitfall
but here he knows that well he gets out
of the opening with a equal position
he'll be able to finish his development
Castle short and then it's a standard
equal position where in order to lose
you have to make many inaccuracies or
many mistakes and Jan definitely feels
somewhat of relief there but long term
long term he could get outplayed as ding
to me it feels like dinks is the player
with a little more experience a little
more feel for these kind of structures
but well a very long way to go and uh
not to ruin it but a very slow
um very slow maneuvering game is
incoming for us I think this one will uh
it will take him a while before it gets
too exciting
yeah London systems kind of London
system players Ultimate Fantasy that
slow maneuvering game yeah but uh for
the viewers perhaps uh not the most
exciting yet but it will heat up later
judging by the way this match has gone
and Jan does sit back down at the board
um what moves are we predicting here
either you put some pressure on that
Bishop that's just landed on B5 I guess
or you develop with Bishop D6 try and
trade off those dark Square Bishops
immediately
and uh okay that's what Yan does go for
a natural move
yes and when preparing for Carlson you
have to look at these positions quite
deeply because Carlson he likes playing
them uh he likes even playing the most
innocent versions of things like even
that are not threatening he just wants
to maneuver back and forth so I suspect
Yan would have looked at these kind of
positions in great depth uh just not not
just Bishop B6 castle and let's play but
even uh further down the road he would
look at the plans the ideas you know uh
what how does the play continue where
does the F6 Knight go is it going to
towards E4 is it going towards D7 do you
push E5 do you push F6 E5
um do you give up the F5 Bishop do you
keep it with H6 all these questions do
you go for B5 or do you wait with D5 or
are you afraid of before after B5 are
you not afraid of before after P5 all
these questions that come to mind I
think would want to have them answered
in your prep if you're facing marvelous
Carlson and I suspect that this is
leftovers from that match uh because I I
guess you don't need to prepare 10
different systems against London so
whatever you prepare for Magnus you can
use for ding
yeah and I guess that's the difference
between these kind of really Elite Grand
Masters uh or these uh top players in
the world compared to some of the rest
of us me for example I would stop my
preparation around here I'd say okay
black is fine I'll work it out at the
board but uh at the world championship
level they must have played training
games in this type of structure they
must have gone into detail that you say
about the plans the pawn breaks where
you want to put your pieces which pieces
to trade off and
um yeah I really like Black's position I
just think he's uh got a kind of moral
Victory out of the opening but that's
not to say he's ever going to be better
necessarily
we're in for a long long grind this game
and uh any predictions on which plan Yan
will go for you know him is he going to
go for something maybe
um just kind of in the needs of the
position or
I don't know if you can whip up anything
Dynamic here as black which he would
love to do of course
I think Newcastle short right I mean I
well you could make a case for
for
I don't like the move but you could make
a case for Knight D7 because you could
say maybe you are afraid of taking on
c6n95 which I think you're really not
you're really not because of C5 there
actually but uh
yeah well I mean making a case for long
Castle would really be insane I think
that's a horrendous uh idea
in this position I think this is really
quite outrageous you do you create the
same balance for no reason at all King
is very weak on the queen side you don't
think you'd want that
yeah and I I I honestly don't don't know
uh okay well uh sorry I think I that
there is maybe maybe a thought that uh
at the castle there is Knight H4
although then there is also Bishop G4
keeping the bishop so I was about to say
maybe you want to play H6
um because I'm trying to understand why
he's taking his time at all this Castle
is sort of so natural but first of all
he has a lot of time but secondly maybe
Knight H4 is a question but yeah Knight
H4 uh can we met by Bishop G4 where I
keep the Bishops and also I don't think
Bishop G6 is the end of the world but
maybe you want to if possible avoid uh
giving up the bishop for now
so Jan taking his time uh but what
happens after Castle uh yeah that will
be a bigger question also the question
is on ding does he want to trade the
bishop on B5
um with the Knights or does he does he
he just planted there just for fun and
uh will it retract later to F1 all these
questions and you mentioned that you're
happy with the blacks position I think
you'd like certainly equalized but in a
way if you if we reverse the colors uh
you know what people very often do these
days try to imagine if black was white
and white was black then uh White would
then be black wouldn't have also
comfortably equalized at this point so
it's a matter of perspective I guess we
have this equal playable position and
it's a matter of choice and taste which
side you prefer
yeah exactly if I was ding here I would
be thinking oh it's been a disaster no
Advantage out the opening but if you
give me his position when I'm black I'm
like yeah this is my dream survive the
opening solid physician no trouble at
all
um yeah could he also be thinking about
kind of asking this bishop a question
I'm not sure why he's delaying castling
on the same boat as you
it looks so natural to just castle and
kind of think later but Jan clearly has
something on his mind
yeah you can definitely mark an argument
for A6 uh I would be uh
a little skeptical first of all I would
wonder maybe white wants to take on C6 I
mean in a good version so maybe that is
that will also I have to move like Queen
A4 after A6 but the reason you could
suggest A6 before Castle is that after
A6
um I don't have for example if you if I
Castle first I can play Baby rookie one
and Bishop to F1 yeah all I have I mean
I really don't think that's a big deal
but I'm trying to find an argument for
playing A6 before Castle
I think nice yeah I mean he was trying
to be precise and just taking his time
but I think it's very hard to make to
make a case for a move other than Castle
on Dick Blazer q1 actually dink dink
actually maybe
um he was kind of not happy that young
played the system because he didn't have
anything special prepared for it if he
does play quickly so maybe
he he you know he he didn't mix anything
up or he didn't uh there was no
surprises for him he just was a little
annoyed that young played one of the
very good systems that he had nothing
against and now okay he just plays what
he prepares because he plays pretty
pretty quickly yeah
yeah but then again it's a bit like
Black's last move castles rookie one is
also White's most natural move and what
else basically so uh yeah a little bit
yeah yeah or just trying to get in the
flow trying to speed up uh yesterday the
clock played a huge part on ish right I
was just watching from afar but uh it
looked like Jan already had kind of uh
settled things psychologically by
playing so fast in the early stages
thing was suffering that
a bit later on yeah and I looked up with
the database
um there are one two three four five
games of gatakamski here with the white
pieces all played in the very
prestigious title Tuesdays and uh kamski
is known to be really an expert in this
slow kind of maneuvering games he loves
this kind of positions he he hates for
prep he loves playing chess uh slow
chess he likes very much and not
surprising is katakamski that we see
here and I think yeah probably
um
think you know you might have uh might
have gone for this uh
kg kind of setup nothing too exciting
for people that like forcing preparation
that like sharp opening ideas but from a
perspective of what dink needs I think
believe it or not it could could be a
good game plan yeah not too familiar
with these structures in general
maybe just hoping to outplay Jan the
computer of course says position is very
close to equal or actually equal
completely but slowly you cannot play
um your opponent especially as we had
seen in the previous Carlsbad game so
maybe some deep psychological thinking
there by uh by ding but of course for
Yan uh there are really very very
um many options and it's really hard to
lose this position of course you can
lose it but it will it will lose the
position you have to make many many many
mistakes and um you know you it tends to
be very gradual
yeah either lots of small mistakes in
each or one big one that's uh how my
experience is going against the London
system
um you may you mentioned the famous uh
legend himself gatakowski how do those
games go uh is ding taking inspiration
is kamski part of the secret part of the
ding team
well uh uh yeah it will be surprising if
akowski would suddenly be uh in Zing's
team kakamski is known as a well well of
course a famous uh Legend but
um he he's known to sort of be a great
great player who really doesn't want to
spend much time preparing so I I don't
think he would uh he would be like
enthusiastic about
helping someone else prepare like he
would probably not mind playing some
training games but I'm not sure that
kamski would be the person to jump on
the opportunity and uh you know become
one of the seconds who suddenly start
shaking openings he didn't even want to
do it for himself I doubt he would want
to do it for somebody else but he
actually won a fair share of this he has
four four against one
um and he played differently so one of
the games after A6 he played Bishop to
F1
another game after Queen C7
[Music]
um
also awaiti movie 2.6 uh in other game
he went after Queen C7 Knight to E5
all three are a completely different
approaches but it seems that yakomski
was just sort of uh freestyling here
playing different uh possible plans all
plans are leading to different positions
that are all roughly equal so it's not
like comsty had it all worked out and he
had one way of playing it he just sort
of just played this position and he
demonstrated all possible ideas on 95 as
one taken 95 as the other and Bishop of
one back is a third third way to play
just get the bishop out or maybe play a
for end then yeah it's
you you shoot some do something with a
knife like very often what happens is
the D2 Knight lands on D3 right David
this is what we learned sort of um yeah
uh this is what we learned in our chess
Kindergartens
sometimes you chase this bishop yeah
yeah I was gonna say D3 is the dream
Square for the White Knight and D6 often
for the Black Knight
yeah I think the reason is that you
could sort of control this square and
also the important B4 Square as well and
potentially after B5 where you played B4
even C5 Square as well Knight 23 is the
kind of doing this multi-purpose tasks
also a knight H4 is possible to trade
this bishop and then the other one can
go to F3 so this is sort of the future
like I could see for this Knight on D2
yeah and uh you're talking about the
minor pieces uh there because you
mentioned the chess kindergarten as well
uh when I was young I was taught these
kind of structures actually Bishops
aren't that important Knights tend to be
the more kind of flexible piece the more
valuable piece uh but it was only maybe
in the last five years or so I realized
from London systems from caricons which
often end up like this that um actually
the lights go Bishop for white can be
quite important uh the Bushman Knight
combo against the two lights tends to
end up with a slight Advantage for
weight
um so do you think there's something
that Yan's may be trying to avoid if you
gave me this position 10 years ago I
might have just gone Bishop G4 and
traded off oh yeah yeah yeah is that
what you mean it is true that uh
it is true that that's what they used to
do uh and and now the engine doesn't
like it as much that's a good good point
yeah yeah this is a good point the
bishop G4 takes F3 this is an old uh old
Instinct that I no longer have uh I kind
of got rid of it but it's true that is
how they used to play it
well it's not the end of the world I
mean I as black I
can Envision various plants so there is
you are actually a big expert here I
realized because of the karokan
experience I remember you beaten level
narone in the famous game where Hikaru
looks you know you guys know you
probably know the chess fans who are who
know just for a long time and know this
YouTube meme where Hikaru looks at the
board and there is level on there you
guys know this meme it's David there
playing the Carlsbad against Levon
the transfer has already has already
occurred so yes thank you but um no the
you are definitely a big expert on these
structures young plays H6 as you
mentioned keeping that uh light squared
Bishop that um
sorry the last quarter Bishop that is uh
important as you had mentioned uh
yes uh I think one big question in this
kind of positions is
does black
go for the minority attack with a6b5
because that is actually the standard
the old way of doing it but I think very
often more often than not after you do
this A6 B5 white will just go B4
then the knights heading to C5 the pawn
will go to A4 and you will just create a
weakness on A6 for yourself so I think
they don't rush it with if I have very
often these days and another question is
sometimes black just chooses to prepare
E5 and accepts isoleni and just holds it
this is another way of playing I think
both of these are not necessary
a big question I guess with this F6
Knight like uh you want to throw it in
or you want to throw it back to support
E5 square one of the the two ways
sometimes they even do like with after
H6 is less likely but sometimes what
even happens is some sort of a
um I was going to say some sort of a
Stonewall with F5 but Dingus played 95
uh you'd usually make this move when
black cannot recapture uh
then it's a very safe move here because
you you have a fork on
on the queen under Knight
so 95 is a safe move I guess Jan will
might play Queen C7
and then he introduces the idea of
capturing the Knight and then white has
a choice to take on C6 with a bishop or
with a knight
yeah
um what do you think ding's plan is
maybe we can jump into a board and uh
play a few lines play a few moves
because Knight E5 very direct approach I
thought maybe white would uh just
maneuver a bit first but as you say
queen C7 would be my first instinct
Again by analogy with some other uh
openings to the karakan uh because this
is a bit of a strategic threat I think
if black trades off one set of minor
pieces uh happily and should be okay
you mentioned taking on C6 I don't
really like it with the Knight just
because black gains time and gets to
play C5 next move no no no I I it looks
it looks uh uh very yeah it looks very
dumb to take with the knight in details
I lose a Tempo and then indeed the C5
comes and it feels wrong I I feel you
know I have this big urge like I see
potential uh for taking it before
and then the slide squared Bishop on F5
it could kind of be a bad Bishop that is
like staring at all these light squares
but doing nothing and my other Knights
can head to C5 sometimes so I could see
I could Envision as sort of a good night
but Bishop kind of scenario here but I
think it's a long way to go I think you
start with A5 probably you want to get
rid of this um potential weakness after
or the bar is liking white by the way uh
what do you do here you just go A3 or
there is something more maybe just maybe
even Knight B3 sometimes I'm not sure if
that's too ambitious with the Knights
yeah yeah yeah maybe that's actually
smart because I was wondering after A3
just for uh because I wanted to kind of
keep the pawn structure more uh more
I don't know what's the word like more
solid like it's up to CB the D4 Pawn is
uh of course it's not really weak but I
wanted to keep the post structure this
way uh but I was wondering after A3 like
how are Traders is to play A4 and take
away the B3 Square from the Knight
I don't know it's maybe a big weakness
and I just go to C1 C4 yeah no I think I
have completely misplaced this position
looks one C4 just looks very good A4 is
a weakness probably
yeah
so maybe a small strategic threat then
uh unless Yan has some immediate way to
kind of simplify that that you were
trying to show with A5
to take this Knight
yeah I think if I would take with the
bishop and gold before I don't know if
I'm better with white but at least I
would feel a little bit excited I would
feel like I'm playing for something I
already see uh I see the outlines you
know of how I could win uh this good
night against but Bishop kind of game so
the other approach by Jan could be to
just go 97 and avoid this
mm-hmm
yeah that doesn't strike me as a Yan
type of move I quite like it as well you
could imagine the bishop dropping back
eventually the night coming out to F5
maybe jumping back to D6 makes a lot of
sense long term but
uh I guess Yan plays good moves and it
is potentially a good move so maybe it
is his type of move but maybe not the
first instinct to retreat
um
no and the Knight on on E5 is then what
I really like here for what is that
maybe it's an illusion of an advantage
here but I like that the Knight on E5 in
this position after 97 it is a very
firmly sitting on E5 nobody is uh
targeting it in fact it might be a
stretch but I could see um H6 move 11
being inaccurate already
and I think the fact that Ding replied
so fast suggests that actually ding was
prepared for this position
because I I think instead of H6 on move
there was really something to say for
the standard move 27. I think they do
this really very often and the idea is
after 95 I can now take on E5
and after d I have maybe Knight to E4 uh
I have lots of options here
um
or maybe not even to
G4
maybe yeah because of the concrete yeah
the computer likes G4 because Knight F3
I have Bishop P4 and F4 I have Queen C5
so maybe good for uh black uh so Queen
C7 uh move 11 yes and because then after
Queen C7 if you take Bishop C6 first
first of all
yeah I could take with the queen but I
guess if I take with the pawn
the position is a little different after
95 I have C5 and after B4 maybe I can
make a move with my F6 Knight and then
meet 95 with F6 so it's a little bit of
a different uh
a different game and also I can take on
cities with the queen actually
keeping the pawn structure as is is also
a question
yeah what what is what that position
would would be maybe you go Knight E5
you have a nice night but I've kept my
Pawn structure uh intact and I don't
have this potential weakness on C6 so I
think this move H6 the young played it's
uh was not a must there's also an option
to go Knight D7 here
for example maybe the Knight H4 would
pick up the bishop but maybe that was a
lesser evil also it's possible to go
Knight E4 so there were options not sure
H6 was the only move because after h695
he has a question for you and does he
allow the Knight to stay on E5 or uh
does he allow Bishop takes C6 trade
uh yeah you know ding is getting
something I think probably 97 feels like
it's a stronger move but it's it's a
difficult one to make yeah and I was
going to ask what happens if black plays
Knight D7 here which piece do you
exchange uh kind of how do you resolve
that tension but uh either way Jan has a
difficult decision to make strategically
he's gonna look into the future here I
think you're right actually H6 is kind
of a useful move but
is it top priority maybe not it feels
like Yan just kind of playing by hand
there and only now is he probably kind
of tanking properly thinking
uh but already
yeah not too Pleasant this decision I
think we will see a lot of maneuvering
if 97 happens then um this game is Just
Gonna maneuver for the next 20 moves and
the way like is is uh G4 a way to
prepare I mean I would not do it but is
it way too premature to go G4 F4 f97
let's jump in and check maybe and uh
Knight to E7 yes while an hg4 you woke
up on the wrong side of bed today just
want to Checkmate no no I just want to
you know it feels completely it feels
completely mis-timed but I just want to
show something and take a look at I
think 94 you have here it's yeah
if you didn't have 94 then maybe but so
it was important to control the E4 it's
important to control the E4 Square
before you push F4 I guess that is the
the definition of of how you should do
it because once Knight jumps to E4 the
problem is not necessarily only the
Knight there but the problem is that F6
is coming and our E5 Knight has will
have to leave and then the weekends of
the E4 square and the King side will be
telling so yeah no no direct issues with
97.
and I think 97 is is sort of the the
right way to go I think Jan will play it
if 97 which you mentioned at 95 I was
thinking about uh SO trading on Bishop
takes C6 BC 97 Queen D7 and Knight B3 to
C5 I was wondering about that and uh
yeah I mean I I cannot assess this uh
right right right away but there is
there is a part of me that really
worries for of a black hair because this
Blood Square Bishop it could be just
shooting empty air and I have this
Knight on C5 which will forever stand
there you'll never be able to get rid of
it and I could see all sorts of you know
I could I could Envision all sorts of
scenarios where uh somehow these
positions and badly for uh
for black so 97 I think the most risky
move of all actually getting rid of all
the knights and allowing Knight on C5
probably yeah
I agree as soon as I suggested it I was
like oh actually let's not analyze
because this leads to one-way traffic I
used to lose a lot of games uh just like
that good night versus bad Bishop uh
when I was younger but uh yeah a
difficult question for Jan because he's
pretty much committed to those types of
positions uh unless he plays a move like
uh yeah no but I'm wondering even is it
even such a difficult because it's just
even such a difficult choice because the
more I think about it the less I see
what's wrong with Knight E7 uh I I think
you know 97 is uh
by far the most strategically safe move
you could allow Bishop C6 BC before in
some version in some circumstances but
you know
so so hard for a human to assess where
it's okay I would think that maybe if
you get F6 E5 somewhere
um
and you get good country play in the
center you could afford this weakness on
C6 but uh why bother sort of um why
bothersome if I play 97 I mean you will
have to play Slowly I guess
You'll Play A Move Like A4 maybe first
question will be by the way if white
will trade light squared Bishops with
Bishop D3 or not yeah
because
it's gonna say with colors reversed
that's a huge Victory right but uh here
with whites
Maybe
yeah because the good thing for white
after Bishop D3 uh Bishop takes D3
Knight takes D3 I managed to get my
knight on a great square and of course
young culture the culture player plays
97 okay yeah nice and on the ball let's
just show this uh it's the dance of the
knights innish whose Knights are better
placed
yeah another degree is fantastic this 93
92 so these are the ideal positions for
the knights I think so uh it's a very
common idea actually to go Bishop D3
once you have a knight on E5 and not and
not not to take mistake with the Knight
because Knight as I mentioned this is
fantastic here so it controls E5 so but
A4 first yeah two A4 first I like it
more after A6 we might we might go to D3
or we might go to F1 even more ambitious
A6 you know A6 is committed because
after A6 I will uh play with white A5
and maybe 9 b39 C5 somewhere so A6 is
maybe committed I wouldn't go A6
yeah it's normally better not to touch
Pawns in this structure unless you can
kind of force through that Minority
attack like you said earlier with kind
of B5 before because if you touch any
pawns you might just leave weak squares
um I think that's what people have
learned over the last just decade or two
um yeah A4 I like it just asking Yan as
well
uh asking John how is he planning how is
he uh setting up his pieces but uh
meanwhile Anish it's been a interesting
start to the game with the London system
uh maybe not all of you is happy with
the opening choice but it has led to a
very rich middle game and I think just
while Jan Ponders his move let's go to a
short break we will be back with more
action in game six in a few moments
[Music]
introducing World quad the partner of
the Champions chess tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up
worldquant is seeking new talent and new
energy and it's looking at the world of
Chess to help because nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player right no Quan experience no
problem
so
do you think you have what it takes to
compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
World Quant is an official partner of
the chess.com broadcast of the fide
World Championship they're a global firm
that builds complex mathematical models
to identify market inefficiencies now
World Quant brain is bringing together
its International Quan championship in
the chess Community to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists because nobody knows how to
analyze a position better than a chess
player right
if you think you have what it takes
register for the international Quant
Championship head to go.chess.com
iqc or use exclamation mark iqc in chat
and Anish we're back with some moves I
see a look on your face you're not
liking the developments here in the game
for Jan naponishi making some big and
committal decisions no it's horrible it
looks horrible
it looks horrible what's happening here
um I think he's very unfamiliar with the
position because I really don't like
what he has done in the last two moves
I think the movie a6s we talked about I
think it's a positional mistake
because after Bishop F1 if I was coming
I don't think that trading this Knight
this way is also fantastic because not
only seven I think is not a great piece
or maybe I'm
maybe I am underestimating Black's
potential on the king side but I really
don't think so I think if I just take
take play A5 let me pull up the analysis
board so we see that the left position
is still with things to move but here I
think ding will take and play if I think
it's an automatic you block this and
then the Knight comes to C5 the knights
standing
marvelously on C5 after that you can
never kick it out with B6 that's why A6
is a positional mistake and then I will
play even B4 I no longer have to worry
about the C pawn it will be firmly
guarded by the Knight on this file
and oh well I have pressure on this uh
on the Knight on C5 is also pressuring
the E6 Pawn I really don't think that
Knight G6 F6 or anything like that is
coming very quickly and I think black
needs that because well
what else does he I mean he just has I
think his position is really like it's a
horrible position for black and it
happened so fast I I think he's made
one inaccuracy after the other I think
H6 was inaccurate I think 97 was okay
but then I think A6 was an accurate and
I think Knight D7 also it was inaccurate
I think maybe the only way to still
try and make sense of this move is to
just go A5 and or Better or Worse weaken
the B5 square but at least
at least keep control of the C5 square
or you don't need to go B6 so just yet
of course but yeah well even this I I
don't like but there is a this potential
to eventually go for B5 and somehow
break the spawn structure open because
after A6 A5
I think it's drifting
yeah it feels like dark Square
domination is imminent and Yan it's
pretty much just saying okay take my
dance squares and uh Anish just to while
we have the board up just to kind of go
a few moves further I'm not even sure
what black plays uh in this position
let's say I don't know let's move the
queen uh once the Knight ends up on C5
like you say uh there's simply nothing
to do about it even if black ever
captures uh on this Square let's give a
few moves
um let's say here even if black captures
I mean that's even worse yeah it's even
worse and if you'd never take this uh if
you can't take this piece then it's just
gonna stand here for the rest of time
um but David I know there's one thing
side as you were showing maybe I missed
something there uh some detail because
as you were showing the line I realized
after 97 27 A5 You'll Play Queen C7
he has Knight C6 of course so this I
have to take some of my words back I
miss this detail because now it's very
hard to get Knight C5 so I can play like
through K3 Queen A1 but well that is a
little clumsy and while I do it maybe
you strike in the center with E5 so uh
maybe Knight B3 was not accurate can we
take a move back because we can wait for
a 96 and then go before maybe here I
should play
um
maybe Queen A4 first yeah then the
bishop C2 will also so you'll need to
spend one more Tempo maybe also a move
like through K3 or Rook E3 first because
I get started before in fact I can start
with before
yeah yeah this is the right way to go
yeah this is the right way to go yeah uh
so I I think I stick by my uh assessment
I think Jan did play in an accuracy but
uh ding has to
yeah it didn't have to do it this way
and while he does it maybe Jan wants to
do some rookette if I have some
if of course if like get some direct
play in the center with E5 it could be
not so bad for him so it's it's not uh
maybe as bad as it looks now especially
if black plays it very well in the
coming few months but I'm not sure black
is uh black has this if I have break in
a good version here
yeah I agree this seems like it has to
be what Jan is hoping for still
surprising he played it quite quickly
relatively because it's so committal
he's basically banking or kind of
gambling on the fact that he can break
in the center later
is didn't considering anything else
I mean starting here just allows her
night capture I don't think that helps
white at all
um Knight takes D7 looks automatic yeah
at least oh yes I think Dinka cannot
believe his luck so he's trying to
double check and he is trying to uh to
see beyond uh beyond what first comes to
mind so because the first thing that
comes to mind is that you just take an
A5 in IBC and C5 then maybe he thinks
okay Jan is not a bad player so he
probably has a point and he realized
maybe squeezy Sevenfold by 96 then he
realizes well maybe I shouldn't go 9v3
so then there is something to think
about and so he's thinking about it
right now because indeed uh of course
it's the things are not too bad for
black he's got this queen C7 idea
white will have to be a little bit
creative here about getting the Knight
to C5 but uh yeah well I think
[Music]
definitely not something I expected I
thought you we would have much less
action I thought we would have much more
Maneuvers much less committal moves much
less trades uh but uh young plays
something very direct
so uh very risky very very risky
approach strategically speaking and um
I think it's possible to well to explain
I I think another Carlsbad a game where
Jan is not
Jan is not playing the most accurate way
it's a very difficult complicated
structure where you need to have a lot
of experience and I think ding is a
player who is just much more experienced
in these positions
yeah Dana's been playing these positions
since he broke onto the chess scene
while Yan
it's never really been in his repertoire
we mentioned it in game three when he
played uh d4's White got the Carlsbad
and
felt like he was playing by hand rather
than uh yeah rather than kind of knowing
uh what he should be aiming for and uh
that's clearly why he went away from D4
in his last white game and there we go
ding does capture on D7 he's guaranteed
to play A5 next I think if white weights
then black will play A5 without thinking
Anish uh something you showed a bit
earlier
so White's next move you can pretty much
pre-move at this point A5 and uh really
interesting yeah but of course uh I
already missed Dania if you play Dania
here in 15 seconds just he'll probably
play Bishop C2 here and after you remove
A5 he would take your queen on D1
so don't remove please I guess don't
remove uh but just wait for Queen and
then play A5
yeah
this is yeah this is world championship
and it is over the board so no promos
here that's uh yeah I'm sure Dania he'd
find ways to win even if White had this
dumb uh kind of dominant Knight on C5
there would be ways to break out and
switch it around
0.02 Advantage well unfortunately I
don't have access to computer and I uh I
envisioned this Knight on C5 so for me
it seemed like a huge Advantage for
white but maybe I've missed a few
circumstances because chess is a
concrete games I use as a human with you
know we are sort of predominantly random
pattern recognition and we envision uh
positions that are about to come and
sometimes uh we can miss the details uh
on the road to that and so I saw a
position where I go A5 a nice lands on
C5 and that position looks really really
dangerous to me for black but of course
uh maybe the computer points out
um some sort of a some sort of a
concrete resource like Queen C7 first
and then maybe 96 quick E5 the break uh
that pawn structure apart and maybe
quick D4 and maybe you equalize so maybe
that is possible but this was just not
what I immediately spotted so
uh not sure it's 0.02 I think we need a
good computer here to to check
um and very likely even if it's equal it
is probably equal because of a very very
concrete sequence of moves but indeed I
think for now plays the movie A5 that
was the only move
yeah and it is the type of position that
might be equal but if black is
inaccurate like you say or if black is
just one move too slow plays a lazy move
then it could turn into a plus one uh
Advantage immediately so
um yeah the London system maybe I need
to add it to my repertoire I'm liking
these kind of slower positions right now
you don't play the London system this is
meant for you David
you genuinely think so like you you like
these 200 Move games this is where where
it starts
you heard it here very well it's it's
the ready it's the ready of 1d4
if I start playing it consistently and
you I'll stop blaming you uh
my opponents can blame you even yeah I
think your opponents will will regret
yeah they'll be like oh you know our
life is no longer the same after David
had this commentary with that Niche one
day it's now itself it's all London no
it's uh well I have to say it in uh
defense of the black players like uh
there were options like early on I
pointed some systems where the queen was
taking opponent B2 so it's possible to
try and get these London players out of
their comfort zone
but if you play a system like this one
where you go cded and just play slow
cars about then yeah you are up for a
long game and indeed young plays Chris
is seven so he uh he had this um he had
this all anticipated
so I was a little bit too too harsh
there at first I missed the Queen's
seven idea so I take all everything back
and I I will we'll have to wait and see
we have to wait to see if ding does get
an iPhone C5 then indeed odion has done
will be a mistake but if Yan manages a
quick E5 break and uh everything will be
traded then Jan's judgment would have
been very very deep let's see
yeah I'm just thinking Anish uh I'm
obviously from the UK and uh the two
games I've been or two of the three I've
been here for one was an English opening
and now it's a London system it's as if
you know the start of the line the chest
gods are trying to say something yeah no
the the monarchy is you know
coming for us and uh yeah very very
impressive of course I mean uh
it's a generally an interesting topic
you know the names of the openings uh
there are some openings are named after
uh country some after cities some after
animals like there's the orangutan and
all this kind of stuff and uh it's some
of the players of course it's all a very
interesting uh
yeah interesting uh topic and uh
even some openings or variations they
have names and many strong players don't
know of these names and that's like a
whole yes there's there's a whole uh
culture of uh giving openings names
and London and uh there are even a few
that for example the Vienna you have
multiple viennas I think
yeah that's in the Queen's Gambit uh
kind of decline a bit later accepted and
then uh also in one e45 and ic3
uh would you wish uh any openings were
named after you Anish I guess we were
born in the wrong generation a little
bit delayed for that exactly everything
is already taken everybody already got
whole dips on everything so it's hard
um I mean it's a big question let's say
if Greenfield contributed the most to
the Greenfield I have my strongest
doubts uh whether he did but uh well he
was one of the early players to play it
and he he named it after himself
and make sense yeah and you know
Carlsbad I mean I I think there was a
tournament in Carlsbad I I guess and
that's when they play these structures
but uh you can you could safely
you know you could you could safely find
a player who has contributed a lot to
these openings as well and uh yeah I
don't know what the English have done to
to get the entire 1c4 named after them
um really not sure but uh
but here we are yeah there's plenty I
could say about that and we take what we
don't deserve but uh yeah uh either way
that was the English opening on C4 in uh
in game four and now it is the London
and uh
yeah ding thinking I mean there's
clearly one plan in the position right
uh White needs a knight on C5 it's just
how to arrange it how to set that up
yeah I'm also wondering about oh sorry
go on a niche no I just want to make a
point that it is a very very important
moment because as E5 is inevitably
claiming uh coming sorry I'm starting
reading the chat and somebody wrote
claims so I sort of coming as a claiming
but uh yes E5 is inevitably coming and
then you want to make sure your pieces
are positioned in the best way that's
why so that you can take on E5 and then
establish a block on D4 and you don't
want your pieces to be in the way so a
big question let's say you want to go
Rook A3 before or Rook E3 before or
queen F3 before uh very very important
moment maybe like something I maybe
quick enough they're actually possible
because after Queen F3 if you go Knight
C6 E5 is not an option maybe you don't
mind after queen of three even to go
Queen G3 sometimes and game probably is
I don't know who benefits from going
into an end game but why it certainly
doesn't mind I think if you get an
iPhone C5 in an end game as well so a
big big moment for ding here as the
natural Knight B3 is made by 96 you have
to do one of these moves that prepares
before and uh now the more I look at it
the more I like the move Queen F3 but my
first instinct was Rook E3 so definitely
some options there for thing
yeah actually I was attracted to Queen
F3 as well I'm not sure how black meets
the threat of or the idea at least of
getting the Queens off uh maybe we can
show what might happen if the Queens do
come off uh in an end game if we bring
up a board uh Queen F3 here
let's assume black replies in the way he
wants to Knight C6 attacking this Pawn
we have time for Queen G3 and suddenly
it's not so easy for black to avoid the
queen trade unless you
do you really want to play Queen d8 uh
White will play this B4 and that B3 idea
anyway E5 is not coming no counter play
and if you do get the Queens off the
board unless black again is quick to
strike with E5 I'm not sure he is and uh
yeah Knight and C5 could spell disaster
I'm surprised the evaluation bar is not
reacting here it feels pretty beautiful
yeah yeah no but I think the we got
trolled there by the chat uh it's not
0.02 I now uh just checked on uh on a
good engine that I'm uh Cloud engine
that I rented just to be sure and uh
White has a huge Advantage here after
Queen F3 I mean okay huge
like how huge can such a position be but
to how big it can be in this kind of
position it is huge so uh Queen F3 is
the best move and um between G3 also B4
like Alpha 96 even B4 is stronger like
this we don't need to rush and then we
are finals in Middle game and I love the
fact between F3 that I stopped E5 and
now you are really uh if you don't get
E5
well you're really in trouble I'll bring
my knight to C5 and I can't trade Queens
I can also postpone it I think middle
game and the end game both are better
for white so uh and I hate your knight
on C6 by the way it's a horrible piece
there unless you go E5 it's the only way
to justify the Knight there and I'm
sorry I call it your night it's not at
all your night is I'm glad it's not my
night no after Queen F3 uh black black
is uh
like is much much worse and the kind of
evaluations that like the com the little
little gives 0.3 which is uh very very
high for Lila it's like calibrated in
such a way that 0.3 is a big advantage
and uh especially in the Carlsbad
structure to get a 0.3 by Lila that is
uh
yeah this is really a lot you have to do
a lot of things wrong and I think Jan
has done a lot of things wrong a lot of
unnecessary decisions and uh I I think
with F3 is also Dingle plate like it's
very easy it's quite obvious to me also
this is a very good move so dingo play
Queen F3 I think and then
difficult for for the end I think you
should go look fc8 or something like
that to at least prevent before for now
and then the white goes Queen G3 now I
want to bully your queen away if you go
Queen d8 then I go before probably a
knight B3
and so after 23 you can then go for the
end game but the end game is very sad
and it's very early actually but I am
already going to call it I think uh ding
fans uh can get their uh well you know
their heads out there this whatever
trombones or whatever they have and
start uh prepare for celebrations
because I think uh this is going to be a
good day for doing the position is very
easy to play it's completely risk-free
and it is totally fitting ding style and
the Yan uh well definitely doesn't uh
doesn't uh like what he is going to be
seeing in this game so very optimistic
for ding already
mm-hmm and as ding thinks about his move
let's look back on how he was feeling
yesterday after going down in the match
three to two and how much this bounce
back would potentially mean to him
this time this lose
um I didn't hurt more than the previous
one because I thought I was totally
fine
so but okay we have still have many
rounds I hope I can recover from this
tough losing
and yeah Anish uh ding saying it there
himself uh of course this game would be
huge for him he's already got a better
position we think uh the type of
position that suits him that uh Jan is
maybe uncomfortable in
and are you sticking with your
prediction big words thinking he's going
to strike back here yeah yeah I'm
calling it you know I uh 80 chance that
he was going to win uh
I think like like who's watching this
game is just face palming because you
know he he's a big uh big fan of
carlsbats like he loves uh I'm not even
sure he plays them as well as he loves
them like he loves them so much and he
is always happy to get a Carlsbad
sometimes in some complicated Cubs but
he even can make mistakes but in the
clear-cut positions like this one Magnus
really excels when it's all very clear
and the post structure is clarified and
there is no uh no murky play on the king
side against the king and when um it's
all about the squares and Maneuvers I
think Magnus really understands these
things very well and I think Magnus must
be shocked looking at this game seeing
how quickly things deteriorated for uh
for black hair well he must be loving
White's position as well and I think
he's a little bit jealous of things
sitting there you know at the world
championship chair he wants to he's
thinking today he's a little bit of a
fomo I think you know it's all I could
also be sitting there against the young
I could you know I could have also
alerted this position so
yeah the 2021 match could have been a
lot more straightforward if Magnus has
picked up the London system potentially
but I think it was straightforward it
was enough in the end as well let's
let's give him some credits where the
swords do yeah perhaps and uh it all
comes down to this A6 move you mentioned
that you don't like many of Yan's
decisions I just I just hate this one
decision to put the pawn on A6 it was so
unnecessary you could have basically the
same uh same position but with the idea
of kicking black uh kicking the White
Knight out of C5 later if you need to
with B6
just feels like putting all your pawns
on light squares
strategically just horrible for Yan and
there we go Queen F3 what we thought was
the strongest move from ding really
powerful staff multi-purpose and he gets
up I think Yan maybe now will start to
realize the damage he's done
yeah to his position yes yes sir he will
he will he he has a good chess
understanding of course when he's
unfamiliar with the position and his
impulsive style he is able to make a
mistake
um but with understanding that he
possesses
it will Dawn on him I if it already
hasn't uh well that what he has done is
is wrong when you mention the one
mistake A6 I I could uh argue for you
know a second one here because in fact
you can even hear if you pull up the
analysis boards a weekend after A6
Bishop of one we could have then played
A5 with black and it really wasn't the
end of the world for example the
computer also doesn't hate it so much
for black
the weakness of the B5 square is a lot
less significant than that of the C5
Square because here after B6 if you put
let's say the bishop on B5
you will never be able to attack my
pawns I can play B6 I can free my Rook
potentially for uh some action on some
file somewhere at some point later on in
the game and uh here your knight doesn't
have the access to C5 Square my pawns
are nicely protected you don't have uh
before it's not tempting nor is C4 we
can before Square so this is a very
decent setup for Black I would rather
have with the Pawns of course on A7 B7
keeping flexibility and keeping also the
minority attack as an option but this is
definitely not the end of the world
while
after A6 and then going 97 I think this
really is uh second mistake but yes of
course A6 was played with the wrong idea
so you could definitely say that A6 was
the main inaccuracy I would also say
that of course for example the movie H6
was unnecessary but it was not such a
big deal as um
as this A6 move move was and yes
basically a sequence of decisions uh
each probably with the wrong plan in
mind
uh to be on in a significant
disadvantage here and uh he will realize
after queen of three which he probably
missed
um that situation is very difficult and
I don't know what to suggest for him
here and
I read the notice I just from here but
uh yeah things are not looking good
because besides the position objects
we're not being very good it's just
stylistically it feels ding so much like
I could when I when Dinka played of
Queen F3 I told you that he will do it I
know uh thing I know his strengths
in a position like that like if I
understand that quinjetree is best I
know ding understands that Queen G3 is
best like I there's sort of things like
I trust I trust think uh with and uh
converting a position like that is
something I trust him uh trust him on
how would you put that style into words
an issue you mentioned it's this feeling
you just know you kind of get this
Instinct that he's loving things but I
mean a lot of the viewers will know him
as a dynamic player he's won some
beautiful games in his career but also
strategically he's just extremely strong
right
yeah I think so what what is happening
here is uh it's a position with a fixed
Pawn structure
so uh when the spawn structure is fixed
you kind of know where the pieces belong
so think very quickly realizes the
Knight belongs on C5 he very quickly
realizes that E5 is Black's only Pawn
break and uh once he you establish all
these uh things and there is nothing
complicated there is no control plan
against the king there are no Dynamic
factors the factors are very static the
ideas are very clear-cuts to a player of
a level like Ding and then it's just a
matter of uh considering options and uh
one by one there is rookie three there
is Rook A3 there is Queen F3 and very
quickly you see that while rookie 30k3
allows E5 23 does not and that's already
enough to make Queen F3 so and then you
also as a bonus you know the screen G3
idea and all that so uh it is really a
very easy move for someone that there is
a position who is a positional player
and I think ding is actually
predominantly a positional player he can
calculate extremely well and he has had
some beautiful tactical victories as
well but uh in my own experience against
ding he is a great positional player
especially in a typical D4 type
positions so we speak now carlswald
structures we speak the Catalan kind of
uh situations
um this this type of post structures his
family he knows where the pieces belong
and uh yes now he
he is thinking and uh young just played
Rook FCA this is a good good move of
course um trying to prevent before and
this is where I suggested Queen G3 going
for an end game
is that the only approach I guess the
White Knight can start trying to hop
into C5 already
um
well 1996 right 1996 was always the
issue okay
tricked me that Niche yeah the move
order may be important so uh offering
the queen swap off from the queen trade
makes a lot of sense right now
um let's just put that on the board
maybe
um because it was the first move that
came to my mind Knight B3 uh but I
placed Knight C6 and I'm tied down to
this weakness on A5
well details that are important and
queen G3 now you just Retreat and still
stuck
slightly at least although Knight C5
here maybe uh day five and before before
okay you've got a calculator
it's B6
yeah before B6 important yeah
oh and it's fine yeah yeah it's it's
fine no but but you know already when
you play Queen FC already now like 93 96
already was a thing on the queen C7 so
I'm pretty sure that uh
no after X8 the only question I I have
so you you want to play B4 and Knight B3
because 93 is 96. you can play before
because the pawn is hanging on C3
so you could somehow not want to go for
an end game if you are white maybe like
you could go Rook E3 now
which is Rook on E3 is not harmonious I
can move the bishop away and then Knight
F5 is coming I don't like rookie 3. uh
it's really I don't like it but don't
make me make this move please I also
don't like Rook ec1 because after rookie
C1 I allow potential E5 maybe not now
because six rookie one and rookie seven
but The Rook kind of belongs on the
e-file in general
so I don't like Rook ec1 either so Queen
G3 is really by far the most harmonious
way of getting my way
and okay that involves a trade of Queens
I think I'd be okay with it maybe ding
is so ambitious he thinks that trading
Queens is making life easier for Yan but
I don't think so I think an end game is
also fine but well maybe maybe middle
game is more ambitious because in an end
game maybe black will just stand passive
play 96 Rook C7 rookie seven they'll
prepare E5
maybe black can hold this way maybe
yeah uh so he could he could uh not play
Queen just 3 because he is too ambitious
but Queen G3 is so nice because if you
go Queen d8 after Queen j3 by the way
then I already have everything I want I
just got B4
and then I'm just coming with the Knight
via B3 to C5 okay I don't see maybe uh I
don't know why the bar is not completely
on the white side here but uh to me it
looks very good
yeah I'm wondering if there are any
tricks here like I don't know Bishop C2
yeah
let's say Rick easy one
yeah I'm kicking you out yeah that's
annoying I wanted you to use the other
Rook so I could come back this way maybe
but uh yeah I don't see anything here
Knight F5 you just move the queen
somewhere
you have some cheaper like Queen G5 Rook
season 9 D4 maybe wow just to put that
on there but I don't know if it's I'm
not sure if it's uh yeah if the result
of position is not lost I go CD Rook
still 93 Knight C5
I don't know
still looking good for white but yeah
it's uh some considerations there of
course uh we just did by far the most
harmonious let's see maybe Rook A3 but
the problem with Rook A3 is that after
B4 I still don't thread on Knight B3
well actually Rook A3 maybe either
Knight b396 Rook ea1 but again I
doubling on the a file this is just it's
Such a Pity to do that the Rogues don't
belong there and so spend so much effort
to establish Knight on C5 while you'll
get hit on by E5 somewhere I don't think
that's necessary
um so let's let's see what are the other
options that you would uh consider here
with white
I'm not sure
um I mean queen G3 like you say is so
natural I was attracted to this one but
obviously it looks uh Clumsy after
Knight C6 so I
I'm less inclined now and yeah all the
Rook moves like you say they kind of
have drawbacks to them so uh Queen G3 I
would
yeah I would Bank a lot of money on
right now but uh of course there are
options I don't think there's a need to
rush you can play like H4 or something
first if you really want to but
um yeah decision fitting actually H4
takes away the option of Queen G3
something exactly yeah I'm not sure it's
a useful move
difficult and yeah the reason I asked
about doing this because uh when I first
played him I think back in 2016 at the
Olympiad
um our coach at the time the England
coach he was like okay just don't get in
any dynamic position just get something
slow and strategic against him and I was
like wait are you sure because he's
pretty good there too uh but yeah that's
what I managed to do when I managed to
Halt um but yeah it's just where do you
target him he's so Universal
especially here where he's going to be
loving life going to be loving his
position
I think the the main weakness of ding
right now is his black reparatory I
think he is his opening reporter with
black as a vulnerable he's uh he's not
as deeply prepared as some of his
colleagues as we had seen so far in the
match for example yesterday he was out
of book at some point didn't know he
planned the right plan in that position
where he could have known it because the
the position has been played before so I
think this is his main weakness like the
concrete knowledge with black is
sometimes lacking yeah I mean if we
already start like nitpicking and asking
why he's not 2900 let's say yeah this is
what I mean that's what I mean in terms
of weakness but uh other than that uh
yeah like strategic understanding uh is
is incredible tactical vision and
calculation is also extremely extremely
good so well he's definitely one of the
best players
um of Our Generation and of all time of
course as the chess players become
stronger and stronger with more and more
knowledge available so
yeah I uh I really am wondering here so
I would Circle in between these moves
that we talked about so I think Rook C1
rookie three Queen G3 I don't see
another uh useful move
so I would be choosing between one yeah
I have to say the big question I would
have is after Queen j3 how big that end
game is now of course white is better I
think that is safe to say
but I I start wondering yes with
accurate not with accurate patient
defense
how much is it is it uh enough for a win
that said I still think that as white
you should we should take the the
opportunity
um
the computer by the way likes Rook is
Rook EC one more I see here wow okay
yeah yeah of course but I think the
computer doesn't really see E5 uh
working out for black Anywhere But as a
human I'll be I'll be a bit concerned by
that
would be concerned about allowing E5
yeah yeah I would be inclined to agree
that Anish just allowing any Central
activity when your opponent's kind of
stuck passive it's counterintuitive for
any human uh you have rookie C1 I'm
really doubting that will happen uh I
saw you pull up the computer then uh
what other ideas is it suggesting I had
one idea I had one idea I didn't want to
say it out loud I was embarrassed but I
had that idea and that is to go G4 and
then Queen G3 but I didn't want to say
it because I was a little bit
embarrassed of that but actually the
computer doesn't hate it at all
wow I'm gonna I'm gonna guess that
that's not going to happen it feels no
no it's not outrageous it feels too much
giving potential probably honestly and
outrageous but after G4 Community
8G you have improved your Pawn structure
quite a bit and you kicked away the
Bishop from F5 which is an achievement
so it actually is like it's actually
sensible
but it's just
your hand cannot make that move here
it's just not not it and the computers
are just a very deep move Rook A2
that is extremely deep
and
well let's let's try to understand so
let's make these moves on the board
perhaps so okay two Bishop G6
ah okay it's basically I think I think
it's like a waiting move yeah he's just
waiting because now after bp6 I have
Knight B3 Knight C6 Queen G3
can you make not Bishop G6 can we make
some other move just for uh okay
Bishop H7 yeah
Knight b396 Queen G3 Queen d8
and now what is the difference uh why is
your recorder
[Music]
yeah strange okay didn't play through K3
the much more human version of that that
same move very nice I didn't uh I didn't
uh dislike this move so much
but you know what I didn't like about it
I yes I didn't like the fact oh but I
don't want to go before I want to go to
NB3 now of course
and after 196
let's say a way to get one yeah what do
I want no 96 328
is it as simple as just playing this
move just to protect yeah and then jump
in yeah so we talked about it we talked
about I said that I don't like doubling
on the a file but you know it's
temporary measure so you maybe double on
the a file then afterwards you plan
tonight you go before you are you go
back with the Rooks yeah I'm just just I
was just concerned that while I do this
uh if I will come at some point if I
have break will come at some point
so yeah it was a matter of choice method
of choice I think my my default would be
to go Queen G3
because I'm okay with end games usually
and I also don't mind uh often to you're
not
yeah to simplify somewhat uh I'm not
terrified if opponent gets drawing
chances but uh think needing a win and
feeling smelling blood he uh plays much
more ambitiously and well very possibly
it's a better better choice so we'll let
him have that
yeah already you see a line for example
passing by by the way which which is
exactly what I don't like it's like
Bishop C2 I like Bishop C2
it has to C1 yes uh Bishop goes back to
G6 a white goes before
and then black and strike in center with
E5
and with the Rook being on A3 slightly
clumsy I feel this can slip away and
black can equalize here so this is the
kind of things I'd be worried about as
white but well we'll see we'll see what
happens
um yeah and it feels like this is the
moment that Yan will have a long think
he knows what's coming the White Knight
is coming in to C5 in the near future
and while he Ponders what to do next for
black let's have a short break we'll be
back shortly with more action from game
six of the 2023 fide World Championship
yes
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
reservation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just block yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in weight
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon him
and Jana promise you once again holds a
one-point lead in the 2023 world
championship match what an incredible
bounce back
ding Lee Rand knows firsthand with the
end of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame Don is just gonna
smash through on the king side ding ding
have a good day this is all over and
what a game I have to say
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
hello and welcome back to game six of
the 2023 fideo world championship
between dingleren and Jan napomnishi as
we see in front of us Yan has just made
a move and ding is now thinking it's
move 19 for him after this turn and
Anish was still liking White's position
yeah of course we do of course we do
um I think the big question is here in
general this position is how
how do players assess Queen G3 trade
because I start getting a suspicion that
Jan is not uh fear does not have fear
the trade and ding does not want to do
it because I think the bishop on G6 is
potentially vulnerable to Queen G3 so I
envisioned a position where the Knight
comes to C5 Black Knight goes to c6a5
and then I have this Knight X E6 idea
where the quinone is on G3
so I think simply uh Jan is okay with
Queen G3 he will just trade the queens
and hope to sit it out and ding will uh
probably also not try to do that so
maybe maybe the position is uh yes uh
more complicated than this and then the
question is if ding doesn't want to play
Ninja 3 then what will he do
yeah I guess the other option he's just
made a move ding uh it is Knight B3 I
was about to say yeah the other option
is Knight B3 first and only then if the
Black Knight starts putting pressure on
the A5 Pawn uh like we were examining
before the break then the decision Queen
G3 or not Queen G3 I'm not sure whether
we need to rush that with white
um I think he's just delaying making
that uh making that call
we haven't seen many end games in this
shot I'm just thinking back in the match
other than maybe you could argue game
one we haven't seen many kind of long
protracted maneuvering positions without
the Queen's on
yeah we haven't uh I think both players
are very good but
having a passive end game I think the
nature of having a passive position it
doesn't shouldn't shouldn't fit Jan's
style because he's opening repair tour
has been neither from the drag sorry
neither of and Greenfield for a very
long time and these kind of openings
they don't lead to passive positions
very often they leads to often they lead
to worse positions but the worst
positions with active counter play so I
cannot imagine Jan being uh happy with
the passive defensive setup
so I think an end game between history
is welcome indeed and B3 first is a good
way to start young will play Knight C6
that's uh given there the question then
is uh does ding then go Queen G3 and
then indeed the queen d8 is met by 95 I
think after Queen just a yard we'll take
an end game because when you are worse
um as a Defender you often have a
tendency to welcome a peace trade even
when sometimes the P Street is harming
your position but in particular in this
case I think it shouldn't harm your
position I think a queen trade is uh is
okay maybe it brings black a little bit
closer to a draw but yeah still a lot of
suffering in the end game the other
question is of course maybe ding does
not want to play with G3 but then I
don't know which move this Rook e to A1
move it's a very clumsy one I don't
think you you'd want it I think then if
I feel like the comment it's a good
moment
yeah I agree it does feel like a thing
maybe objectively should also go for the
end game but uh maybe we should examine
a niche we've been quite kind of harsh
in quite down on Black's chances uh how
maybe we should check out how a boat
title set up once the Queens do come off
um let's jump into an analysis board
sorry and um yeah Knight C6 I'm
expecting as well I don't see anything
else at all for black you can maybe
flick in Bishop E4 if you really want to
end game but uh Queen G3 do you think
firstly is black gonna take on G3 or is
black going to allow the capture on his
terms on C7
oh but if you allow the capture I could
also not capture I could go Knight C5
next I guess and uh go B4 uh though I do
think that
possibly I don't mind to take on C7
um I think you take on G3 probably you
double my pawns I guess
I I felt The Rook should come to E7
because I think defending the B7 Pawn
from the side is the most multi-purpose
way because you don't want to be
defending it from A7 God forbid or from
B8 where the Rook is passive I think
Rook on E7 does a good job at first C7
here or
um a job good job of protecting the pawn
and also potentially uh contributing to
Black's play and I should probably land
on C5 so we can play Knight C5
black code in position like that in
structure like that sometimes but I
could consider a move like H5 uh to try
to it's to try to
cramp the G3 G2 pawn and this particular
case I don't like the bishop on G6
um I'm even wondering after a move like
Bishop P2 how you're going to deal with
it but if you had the bishop on F5 you
could go H5 G6
well there will be an issue that the
bishop would also have little squares
there on F5 but if the Bishops didn't
take like if the Bishops were not on the
board let's say that you you don't want
to play H5 this is the this is the
standard thing that white wants to play
G4 and black wants to play H5
to get on somehow more mobile
um so if H5 is not going to happen then
maybe let's make a move like rookie 7.
yep
and here does white want to play B4 like
they did in the middle game I'm not so
sure because it's nice to have this
option later uh I'm attacking this Pawn
oh yeah good point good point indeed you
have the Rook B3 idea which I didn't see
and maybe even Ruby three Rook B6 and
then before so uh
of course you need Rook eaa1 first and
before key A1 maybe you you might want
to go move like a fort to slow down E5
makes sense yeah maybe you can play a
four and if black plays okay I'm not
sure is a good move maybe Rook a C8 a
little bit closer to because now Rook
ea1 probably very tempting which as you
mentioned rookie A1 as you mentioned yes
and Rook B3 next
um black probably will go for some F6 to
to keep E5 in
in reserve then let's do you do your
group with remover
yeah I want to I see a pawn I'm gonna
try and Rook cc7 let's say
my phone Bishop I'd rather head on maybe
F3 at this point also but okay let's
let's say because now I think E5 is
potentially
potentially coming
I just realized as well in this position
uh there's also maybe some tactics with
Knight takes B7 oh nice oops I just saw
the evaluation bar go up slightly so it
must be a tactic uh must be this one
the show and a skewer
but either way yeah it feels like this
is a lot of pressure for white
yeah the bar is Happy
um no definitely definitely pressure and
uh oh okay actually what I didn't
realize is that inner uh end game
because I was going for B4 Rook on A3 is
actually kind of useful right because
you have this rugby three idea
so I thought a white will go Knight C5
and before and Rook from A3 has to go
back to A1
but now that you mentioned Rook B3 idea
then I think I kind of like the movie K3
like even for an end game it could be a
useful move
and Bishop G6 is not so maybe the
inclusion of Rook A3 Bishop G6 benefits
wide so maybe ding has played it well
yeah of course yeah he's happy with the
end game of course no no he's happy with
the end game he just wanted a better
version
just wanted a better version of the end
game
so in tune with all these little
finesses it's impressive uh Queen G3
and sorry in this position Queen G3 and
yeah I don't like actually the way that
Jan has set up his Rooks if he knew an
endgame was coming anyway then
maybe a rook on E7 already would have
been nice
um
perhaps here
we're kc8 exactly uh I guess he wanted
to keep the option open maybe of late so
playing B6 is black so he kept The Rook
on A8
um just in case it comes to the B file
but
23 okay he's very quickly avoided uh any
Queen trade Queen E7
what do you think of that again feels
awkward but maybe necessary
yeah but I uh I do like it because I
like the like I was I'm obsessed with
this E5 move because I think this is
Black's only source of control play and
so I like this move Queen E7 I uh I
think after Knight C5 he wants to go E5
mm-hmm
and I think the E5 well it gives him
some counter play so I like this move I
like this move I didn't see it somehow
as much assumed Queen did because I was
obsessed with this A5 Pawn
but uh now
that I realized that E5 is possible
um I start liking his uh position again
now uh if we go back to
position earlier dink of course could
play Queen G3 when the Knight was on D2
so he could have gone before Knight B3
now like the way ding has positioned his
pieces is still a little bit
disarmonious so I'm uh overly sensitive
to these things and I I would have
preferred Queen G3 directly because now
Rook a393 look a little bit odd and
Knight C5 is met by E5
so you can't have it all of course
against yes I guess a player like Yan
you can't have it all that the Bardo
says that if I was wow rubbish but I
don't know why
what are we missing here there must be
something
tactical perhaps
or maybe or maybe five maybe just B4 and
let's say E4 is not an achievement or I
thought E4 is definitely an achievement
yeah it's not at all evaluation bar is
really loving this for white
um oh wow
I mean I do with F3 immediately
ah even that just before black gets time
for F5 because this is how you don't
even have a five yeah six is horror
horrendous uh it's it's a horrible piece
and
um indeed maybe F3 is also a problem
maybe F3 is a problem yeah because in
general I think jumping with a pawn from
E6 to E4 is an is an uh is a success but
here
yeah everything is very clumsy the
circumstances are against black the
bishop on G6 indeed is um not allowing
black to play F5 can we just for
arguments can we just play Bishop H7 and
pass and F5 I just want to see how the
computer value is this position let me
play like Rook a two or something and F5
that's quite a useful pass for it yeah
but F5 like let's get a five like how
bad is this still very bad yeah
but it's not obvious for a human that
this is bad uh I've got to say not not
yeah to me not so I mean and I of course
I understand Dwight can be much better
here because of the night but I feel
that getting E4 and F5 would be an
accomplishment uh like a tremendous
accomplishment
creating a lot of control potentially I
could understand if White's Bishop was
like on B3 for example but it's still
very far from there and this Rook it's
not sure where it goes it's not cleared
no not clear what was the issue uh yeah
King HH G5 F4 just trying Pawn storm
counter play
but uh do we think Jan's going to go for
this because potentially I mean this
looks very strong for white the more we
look at it especially kind of the temple
up version that we had yeah exactly no
the problem is the tempo operation yeah
yeah no the problem is that I was just I
was just curious like how bad is this
idea in general but of course the in the
tepo app version we're doing probably
much better
can we just take a look at the position
of the Knight B3 so up to Knight C5 can
I go Knight takes A5 or no this was the
other question I had wow Knight takes A5
feels like something should be lining up
here and this Bishop's a bit loose the
pin is the PIN is on the pin is in my
favor afternetics E6 I can move my A5
Knight and you are the one pinned
actually
although I can play with A1 simply yeah
yeah now now now it's back at you yeah
yeah maybe 96 was premature instead of
96.
what move to make Knight C4
you pick it up while it's pinned uh to
the rook and then this is getting
complicated yeah this is the idea that's
5.95 that's the idea
okay five B6 of course okay five B6 of
course pick the point
yep
subtle stuff here
wow
so actually a hidden trap for ding
potentially thought it might be the
other way around for now uh for Yan but
uh
yeah really clever move Queen E7
I see five Knight takes A5
yeah it's not an obvious stupor yeah
negative five not obvious
and especially after night A5 Knight E6
you can see 96 okay A1 you can miss Rook
C6 there if you don't have the bar with
your brought to the game
do we think it's time this Rook has done
its job maybe on A3 it's a time to go
back just to keep this one defended uh
in some of those lines
oh yeah wonderful moments to to drop the
Rook back
uh
details let's do that excellent
but then maybe black has time to protect
this bishop so that Knight takes E6 is
966 remains it remains an issue because
I will then collect uh yeah
show the difference here Knight takes A5
is less effective because we can take
and
because E6 is a very weak and E5 square
is very nice for the rookie now this is
uh still very good knight C5 Knight A5
is a little trap I guess the thing
should probably avoid The Rook A1
probably a better move but well still
we're going rookie 3k1 back and forth
like you feel like as though maybe like
get some time like get some time to come
up with some defensive resource such as
xenonet A5 and the right version or E5
and the right version it seems that E5
more often than not is not really
working but uh Yan might come up with
with some defensive idea so far he's
already come up with the screen 7 move
he might come up with some concrete
defensive ideas a very concrete player
it seems after all
yeah solving all those problems with
these tricky tactics uh Yan and uh while
we wait for ding to make his move let's
learn more about the topsy-turvy path
ding Loren took to get here
dangly wren's unpredictable path to this
year's fide World Championship was born
from the right combination of good
fortune and persistent gameplay ding's
journey to Kazakhstan almost never got
started travel restrictions in China
prevented him from qualifying for the
candidates the Gateway tournament to the
world championship but when a spot
unexpectedly opened up ding ground away
to earn the vacated seat and punch his
ticket to Madrid
[Music]
his foot in the candidate's door ding
struggled in the first half of the
tournament failing to earn a win and
falling to the eventual winner Jana
pomnishi
but that's when the magic began in the
second half ding began to turn things
around starting with a resounding win
over yanked up Duda we have a victory
for dingley Wren and his candidates
chances are not gone at this time
ding then continued his momentum with
back-to-back wins over Rickard Rapport
and Fabiano caruana
in his final match of the tournament
ding squared off with Hikaru Nakamura in
a battle for second place with rumors
suggesting Magnus Carlson might step
down as Champion second place at the
candidates now had an entirely new
meaning
needing a win ding took advantage of a
missed Opportunity by Hikaru on move 38
and worked steadily from there to secure
the Victory and second place the second
half of the tournament has been his four
wins in seven games
while his runner-up finish at the
candidates was certainly an
accomplishment ding left Madrid without
a seat at the world championship
that all changed later that summer when
Magnus announced he would not be
defending his title
with the five-time champion out of the
mix ding's second place finish at the
candidate suddenly became a golden
ticket to Kazakhstan with the rare
opportunity to cement his name amongst
the distinguished list of fide world
champions much like his opponent ding
chose to skip most of the high-profile
classical events over the past few
months and instead selected to immerse
himself in his preparation to face
neponishi time will tell if that
approach and ding's string of good luck
and competitiveness will earn him the
most famous title In classical chess
and Anish we talked about uh ding's
Journey on previous days but it's been
so unique his path to this world
championship in some ways it feels like
it's a fairy tale it's written in the
stars everything going in his favor and
do you think he's going to make the
comeback is this title uh his destiny
yeah indeed it will all come down to
whether he will finally get it or not
the journey to the world championship is
very difficult but only the ones that
make it you know will write their names
in history and I think the circumstances
so far
they have been difficult for doing but
the fortune when it matters always
smiled his way he wasn't able to play a
lot of tournaments he missed for example
the feeder Grand Prix tournament because
of Visa issues he missed out a lot of
tournaments because of um the lockdown
in China the covet lockdown he also
struggled a lot in the online
competitions where everybody played in
much more favorable time zones he had to
play always in the early early in the
morning basically at night
lots of things were going against him
but when it mattered things really
quite the opposite worked out in his way
he of course got a into the candidates
tournament he got second place there
which never is enough but in this
particular year it was enough to qualify
for the match as Magnus decided to to
skip now Magnus had decided to skip you
know in this year not any other year
where thing wasn't the second so it's he
was very lucky in some sense there but
it will all come down to this event if
he will be able to to win a become the
world champion it will certainly be a
miracle
in a way to take any credit away from
Jing but in a sense that so many
circumstances have really worked out in
his favor that he even got that
opportunity but if he is not going to
win this then um
then you know the fairy tale will not
will not have the that happy end
um that it that it uh deserves so
yeah we'll see we'll see I think a
comeback today is likely but even if he
comes back in this game still a very
long road ahead and um yes the match uh
it's just a crazy match uh so many
twists and turns the players um such
different players have the each of them
have such different strengths and
weaknesses
and it's just very hard to predict
whether ding will finally take this one
home or not but as as for this
particular game uh looking things are
looking good for him although there are
some challenges this position as we've
seen Knight C5 Knight takes A5 for big
big resource there for Yan
but overall it's definitely a favorable
outcome of the opening for Ding and he
couldn't have hoped for a better
position in the modern day when
um mundane era where black players are
so well prepared the end is so well
prepared for the match to get a position
with so many chances so many
opportunities so many drums is not
something you're uh you know you're not
something you complain about
yeah and I've got to admit I did fear
for ding after seeing his first White
game uh in the candidates that you
alluded to uh Anish nepo also uh Jan
also beat uh ding there wending had
white
being lost to game two of this match of
course but last Thursday uh he managed
to pick up the win with the white pieces
in that English opening again
kind of uh cruising here it feels like
or at least in a dominant position and
turning that Trend that's uh that's the
key we talk about the white pieces a lot
but uh in World Championships
historically that's been essential
striking with white Yan did it yesterday
it feels like this is a key game for uh
for ding if he can win this one then
yeah it's a coin toss anything can
happen in the second half of the match
but if he fails to convert this it will
feel a bit like a defeat just feels like
everything's been going in his favor
just like his journey uh to the world
championship he needs to finish it off
so what are you thinking uh he's going
to go for here we mentioned Knight C5
doesn't look so convincing of course
he'll calculate that he'll come to the
right conclusions there because he's so
good at that uh kind of type of
calculation and Rook a A1 I mentioned uh
just before our break it does feel
slightly counter-intuitive The Rook only
landed there two three moves ago on A3
so is there any other plan that he could
come up with I don't think black's got a
threat so one or two moves yeah luxury
to maneuver yes exactly I I don't think
black has a necessarily a useful move
when you made this movie King H7 it
didn't impress very much as you can
probably agree the King on h7s just
looks a little bit odd the question
though is
um can white improve the position like
I'm not even sure Rook a to A1 is such
an improvement as I you mentioned this
Rook B3 idea it's now stuck in my head I
I was a big fan of Rook being on A1 I
didn't like Rook A3 at all but
um well now that the Rook is there we
can try to make the best of it
so we could try to keep the Rook there
but I don't know like I don't think H3
is super useful I think H4 is somewhat
committal I also don't think it's very
useful
um so well difficult Choice here for for
ding wow it makes the match yeah okay
yeah maybe he's no maybe uh I said it's
committal but maybe it's not actually
maybe it's okay yeah a useful move
perhaps maybe he can play Queen F4 next
and then even G3 is uh an option to
reinforce the spawn it's a love uh you
know giving King space is always useful
maybe h4a was uh was a nice useful move
I understand ding I understand them
because he doesn't want to bring the air
Rook from A3 to A1 he wants to he wants
to keep the Rook there for potentially
using it for for the B3 square and
simply just admitting that you made a
move that was not useful this is just
not what people like you want to be
consistent H4 is the most consistent
move
yeah and Denise before we dig deeper
into H4 we are seeing a lot of uh
messages from the featured chat about
your mug is that Magnus maybe you can
show us uh yeah it's a Magnus with the
uem Magnus Magnus wow
from The Legend it's Legends of Chess
yeah I already showed the cup earlier
it's Legends of Chess
um from back in the chess 24 uh just 24
days is that an intentional uh use an
intentional choice of mug today
well you put me on the spot there you
know I have about uh 20 marks I choose
from and uh every day I choose this Mark
so yeah
by the way where can we buy this mug
okay okay just 24. so and I want the
percentage of these sales because you
guys weren't selling mugs for two years
now suddenly there are hundreds of
orders I want my um you know affiliate
code use the code
champ 2023 for for zero percent off
I I feel like I need to up my game now
there's a mug that I kind of want to use
but uh maybe for the next break I'll
bring it over if you gonna sell some
mugs or some other Cutlery like it's
here's the place guys it's not for sale
don't worry it's exclusive but either
way I feel like I need to compete with
you look at a nation okay H4 on the
board what is black gonna play big
question
yeah yeah yeah
um I I like that idea I like the idea uh
when the moment I realized that um black
has no useful move
I started liking the idea of a waiting
move I couldn't see one that looked
pretty but maybe H4 is that one yeah
maybe H4 is that one I I can go get
behind it the question so big question
is if Bishop if Bishop C2 is a thing oh
but it's not so Bishop C2 is Knight C5
Knight A5 Knight E6 and now please don't
forget ladies and gentlemen that there's
a little threat of Queen takes G7
um
oh okay five first okay five b696 here
even stronger
just to show this on the board uh
there's a thread of mates
yeah just to finish it off
boom hit and win yeah Jan already made
his move though so let's uh let's catch
up
okay The Rook left the C8 Square so is
Knight C5 Knight A5 still a thing
or is it no longer a thing and does he
want to go for E5 instead
big big question
um
something I believe here let's try we
have to calculate this let's uh bring
the board back up oh no H5 maybe so 65
Knight A5
maybe H5 oh sorry Knight A5 if you
wanted well I think I think 95 is gone
because of H5 H5 I think
one of the reasons wow and take now okay
five first okay first yeah no there was
a point now and now 96
and now again Rook D5
oh beautiful geometry here Niche and uh
you're hitting this bishop we could see
a position like this one and uh is there
yeah exactly
if that wasn't Queen H4 You could argue
that maybe black can cling on Queen D6
as well like it's like a tactic but this
double attack wins the game beautiful
stuff H4 wow this is literally an eight
move variation but uh it's a key detail
the fact that white can throw in H5
earlier on uh so Bishop C2 uh and rookie
eight okay there was a big difference
rookie eight was played Knight C5 so if
Knight takes it doesn't work he wants
e51 C5
yes and we are going to have this
position which doesn't look
to me optically as bad as the bar
suggests and I can totally imagine a
player like Yan or any other top player
for that matter
um well apart from some really like
apart from let's say Magnus who is
usually like incredible understanding of
this kind of positions but most other
top players I can totally see them
misevaluate this position somewhat
somewhat
because I don't think it's obvious that
this is horrible for black I think E5 E4
feels like an achievement feels like
we're getting some play we're going
forward
and uh
well I'll I'll be impressed if ding will
realize that this is
not
not something he shouldn't avoid at the
same time I think he should also go
nighttime because I'm not sure what
other move he can make at this point
what other useful movie can he make
yeah if I might come either way so you
might as well kind of post up and put
your pieces on good squares first
um should we try and kind of understand
why this is such an optical illusion
because uh to me as well I think if this
was a game situation I would argue that
I'd made a huge gain for black uh I'm
assuming B4 just to solidify this Knight
just to threaten to take this Pawn
sometimes
say E4
again is it just F3 and the structure is
good for white is it just you mentioned
earlier and this Knight is a bit dead
and he's gone in Knight C5 we're heading
this yeah
I I think I think it's the uh
predominantly the fact that a 504 is
very far away from happening and the
Knight on C6
the Knight on C6 that that is a huge a
huge
um factor I think if you had like a
knight on H5 now you could play Knight
H5 F5 I would hope for I would hope the
evaluation would be very different but
the Knight is so far away from action
like where does it even go at the moment
you go for E4 you release the tension
from the center Knight no longer
contributes to E5 and D4 squares I mean
the ninth contributes but it no longer
is relevant because the D4 upon guards
the E5 Square the C3 pawn cars the D4
pawn and once you go E4
like you get excited your e-pawn gets
excited but your knight on C6 you know
it brings a heavy side uh because an
iPhone 6 now is completely uh left
without a purpose and I guess this is
the main factor here that this Knight is
completely out of play
probably that's why black is essentially
playing a complicated position
you could say down a piece to an extent
and this is probably why um it's bad and
I can play Rook A2
switch The Rook across maybe to have to
even
potentially fed Bishop C4 can happen
where I pressure the F7 Pawn as well
um yeah I I can see I can see why this
is so good dink did some calculation
before playing Knight C5 he was nodding
his head a bit I think the calculation
involved Knight takes A5 I think ding
um
also spoil the H5 idea and he was making
sure that it works
this is a very very nice idea actually I
think yes I actually love this move H4
and now that we saw it it was not even
just the abstract improving move but it
was a very concrete one as well so it
was a multiple multi-purpose move very
nice yeah that's what this kind of top
uh top elite players they always have
these little details it was not on my
radar at all and just that detailed it
uh kind of G7 mate Queen h37 mate uh is
so important in all these lines for
tempo
uh wow nice move by Ding and what do you
think Jan we see his body language now
doesn't look too positive he was uh he
was calculating clearly a moment ago is
he looking at E5 now was he relying on
Knight takes A5 maybe having missed
something uh maybe missed this H5 move
that we showed uh what could be going on
in his head
I think he was relying on E5
um predominantly and I think he might
now start slowly be understanding that
this uh is not as good as it looked to
him at first
it's always hard to tell at the same
time
I don't think he has another way uh to
play here
I mean I'm not saying that if iv4 is
good because as we had seen it's not
but I do think that especially if you
play the game
if you're sitting there you probably
think that well you have to make it
anyway
of course one advantage of Pawn being on
E6 compared to E4 is that you have the
potential to go E5
with the idea to somehow absorb the
pressure on the D4 pawn and get some
counter play because once you go E4
after that well you can no longer go
backwards as we know this Danny wrench
once mentioned phones can go backwards
so it's it's important that um
yeah you might want to preserve
flexibility
at the same time well you even have to
deal with Knight X E6 issues sometimes
but potentially
could black try and put a Pawn on E5 a
nation try and leave it there I'm not
sure how I was thinking about how like
you're so tied up here
yeah where do you where do you move the
queen you can you need to move the queen
away yeah to threaten Eddie but you have
nowhere to move it
for example uh Queen S6 yes exactly
and you win a pawn uh in some of these
lines yeah really unpleasant and the
queen often tied down to this point uh
in a lot of variations as well that's
why white tonight is so good
and I have a I have moved here to
improve my position I can play Rook A2
I can uh swing to E2 indeed if needed
at some point after Rook A2 D takes E5
becomes potentially a threat
E5 on the boat
this is all happening you know it
reminds me of uh this is Dink uh this is
ding's kind of game it reminds me of
some of a game I lost today
I also did this E5 E4 thing
I also did that
I did that uh in a slightly different
structure but I also did this if I
before
and I was kind of hoping that you know
it will be something it was a very
similar situation where you go E5 before
and you feel like you know you get some
space in the center maybe some attacking
potential on the king side
but somehow it is just strategically
horrendous for you and
I remember ding playing that game
extremely powerfully that was in sinful
cup it was a brilliant game on his part
he beat me then he went on to win the
tournament and beat Magnus on on Time
Break
so
um for those wondering you know where
where's Magnus they just they should
also know that sometimes these two
players they beat him as well so there's
no uh it's not like they cannot beat him
and that was one instance where Dingus
beat Magnus in a tie break
so uh
I think the dinky sometimes or actually
most of the time he is able to show this
very deep understanding in a position
like that where both sides have
different trumps
and you can evaluate properly which
trumps are more significant and you feel
intuitively but also realize which
pieces are better which pieces are worse
at here yeah so we see the bar is uh in
White's favor it's not obvious at first
for uh to a naked eye twice doing so
well because black has so much space in
the center but I think ding he has this
figured out he has a here's incredible
strategic understanding and he realizes
that he has a wonderful opportunity here
and uh like you say Anish pattern
recognition he's had something similar
before and uh he'll be feeling confident
meanwhile he does move his Rook wow Rook
B3 and uh we'll be back in a moment to
examine the last move that Ding has just
played
wow okay
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book club
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
[Applause]
Mike Klein from chess.com back in Astana
and you know my favorite Olympic sport
was always the biathlon you combine
cross-country skiing and shooting but
here in Kazakhstan it's a little bit
different their own version of the
biathlon is you make your move and your
chess.com game
okay did that and then you go getting
pushed down a ramp by some kids are you
ready goodbye
here we go please
tell my mom I love her and here we go
I know why am I backwards
oh that's the end that's the end the end
of fun Master uh second part of the trip
and
scene
they did it much better than me
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
World Championship 2023 between ding
Loren and janapongishi it has been
heating up just before we went on break
we were saying how much we liked White's
position ding we were expecting him to
just keep control to keep a bind with a
big Advantage but instead he's gone for
something much more direct we've sought
a flurry of moves actually in that break
and uh big changes in this position
Anish yeah it's incredible you just uh
you know go for two minutes uh take a
small breather and you come back and you
know the position has changed so much in
fact ding has gone for a concrete
sequence that we haven't anticipated we
have come to terms with the fact that B4
was a very strong uh slow strategic idea
with a very uh counter-intuitive sort of
uh way that you allow E4 and then
eventually you realize that Knight 26 is
uh completely helpless and all of that
but in fact ding had different plans he
had a very concrete idea in mind which
was also why he was nodding his head
before he was calculating something
concrete and we can maybe show what
happened so after Knight C5 E5
he played this uh Rook B3 sequence which
is completely forced after Rook B3
black has to take on A5 then he takes on
E5 so trades uh A5 Pawn for the E5 Pawn
the consequence is very unclear Queen F6
is the only responsible sensible
response and now things turn I mean it
could it could be a great news for for
Ding and his fans he might have done
something really really good but we have
to wait and see because we are in the
middle of the variation the position
hasn't clarified yet and we are yet to
see what exactly is going on we I can
see the bar is still lacking white a lot
but I have to say I need time to
understand what's going on here
I think I think uh Rook A3 is probably
what he wants to play I don't see and I
mean there is a 97 idea there in the air
somewhere but I think what black has
went to C6
but I'm not maybe yeah maybe we jump in
an issue it's getting complicated so
let's check out some variations on the
board uh Knight D7 you mentioned
attacking the black queen but she's not
quite trapped only one safe square but
oh
kind of one safe ish Square uh looks
good enough to see this variation
yeah but I don't think there's much to
continue here yeah it's just rookie five
now you can check yeah Yep this is the
key detail and next move this Rook drops
black emerges the night up uh you're
mentioning also Rook to A3 in the game
that is the only move yeah I don't I
don't see is there an alternative to
that move
do you see one not that I see unless we
swap Rooks first but I don't think
there's a rush to commit to that
swapping the Rooks yeah but what is the
point of swapping them if after k3u
anyway you're not going to take on E5
are you
do you want to take on the E5 rookie 5
D5 could be six so dubious I mean there
are some 97 ideas
um followed by E6
perhaps
also there is no I don't need to rush it
as well I have moved like before perhaps
I think positionally just I'm doing very
well as well I have E6
um
some things that King side attack
potential no I think rookie 5 is
dangerous after K3
what else what else and why is but why
is Dink thinking that's I want to
understand so what are the Alternatives
what is what is he thinking about
you know I'm I'm assuming it's something
to do with Rook A3 I don't see what else
either
I'm not D7 you can rule out it's very
forcing that variation we showed it's
very linear very direct
yeah I'm struggling uh Anish maybe he's
just kind of fixated on rookie three and
there was something he missed further
down the line or initially whether he
didn't evaluate and
now he's kind of just rechecking that
uh he's spent a few minutes on the move
on this move but you would have thought
that he was
well he could have tanked earlier uh
instead of going for this whole line he
was the one who initiated it right with
Rook B3 yeah it was two moves ago well I
assume he missed something of course
because uh otherwise he wouldn't pause
but okay let's say you missed something
okay you you had a minute already so I'm
just wondering he spends already five
minutes
and well the time is not like it's
running out but it is precious time is
precious I'm wondering just
I just don't see an alternative I
and Rook A3 whatever he missed um is
nothing dramatic because everything is
protected
uh I mean maybe Knight C6 he he missed
maybe that's black and soccer pawn with
Knight C6 and he's afraid after root D5
that there's some rookie one that's 96
you have options you have Knight D7 now
Queen has to go to d8 then you can take
on E8 you have plenty of
um yeah you have moves here you have
everything under control still
I mean there's nothing to to be too
concerned about I I do it five minutes
oh H5 is a nice one
um okay I'll take one D7 it's not like
it's the yeah of the world but this is a
nice tactic but again there are options
so I just don't see uh I don't see the
needs to to waste the time maybe he
wants yeah but taking on the a this is
so uncounter intuitive and so strange
oh whatever yes yeah some intimate so
maybe Queen E3 I'm just trying to look
for other ideas three that is the move
Queen E3 yes Queen E3 23 is alternative
maybe okay maybe Queen three is
alternative maybe but I can take and
think H4 and then okay and then some
move
yeah but it gets complicated at least
that's a move okay okay because I just
didn't see a move but this is this is a
move okay now I uh I allow him to think
okay he can proceed to thinking that's
fine uh but Rookery is probably good
interesting how the game took a
completely different turn is now
extremely Concrete in general this kind
of game suits the end the problem is
that if his position is bad it doesn't
matter what kind of game it is the
sequence will uh will lead to a bad
position but young finally has something
to calculate at least
something concrete because before he was
strategically busted but now he has some
some action uh and it's something to
prove so we'll see uh he didn't think
definitely
definitely taking his time here but um
the bar is still happy so okay three
perhaps yeah Knight C6 I guess because
look at Knight C4 is uh
I can just take and take on B7 probably
looks like a free porn yeah although it
will be not so simple I'll take on E5
play Queen B6 or queen B6 first and then
Queen B2
Queen B6 then Queen B2 um well it's
not looking clear to me I can play
Knight D6 Queen B2 Rook A5 or Rook A4
but
well I don't know the apron is there
some of course I have some I have some
nice tactical tricks like E6 and some H5
is in the air I I love my knight 26
Gucci 3.5 combination but you know it's
a clarified position with limited
materials so maybe a black has play of
Their Own
and ding is thinking yeah
yeah this is a dream for Jan at least uh
kind of psychologically compared to that
passive position that we uh we're
expecting for him and this is the
current position we're expecting ding to
play for K3 go Pawn up most likely but
still messy and yeah Point E3 another
option or Knight D7 all these lines but
yeah big thing he needs to speed up uh I
was actually about to say before the
break uh that I was really impressed by
ding's kind of time usage just really
quick just trusting himself kind of
upping the pressure playing nice
sensible moves quite quickly let's move
24 now at least she's got 44 minutes to
make 16 moves should still be fine right
yeah of course the for now it's fine but
um
yeah if you want you know if you are
rooting for someone in general it's not
like I don't have a skin in the game
here but if you are rooting so if you
look at it from perspective of ding on
his fan if you're rooting for someone I
think you want to see
um speed and confidence right you want
to because the moment somebody thinks
this long you kind of start wondering
well he missed something what is he
thinking about
you want uh yeah you want a more action
there and ding is clearly taking his
time it could also be a positive side he
might be very optimistic about his
position he might be thinking that it's
also it's time to you know to calculate
um a sequence which will lead to a very
good position so he doesn't want to sell
it to short he sees 23 he sees Rook A3
and he thinks one of them might lead to
an overwhelming advantage
but I don't know I mean I really don't
um
I really don't think 23 is that tempting
because you can take and take on H4 but
uh well maybe there is something that
bugs him after okay especially look at
396 I think was also was also unclear no
it did get very messy
um some of those lines we were showing
with Knight C4 also nice C6 as you
mentioned uh just going back with the
Black Knights and that's going to get
the e-file I just really don't like the
decision even if objectively uh the
computer still says it's a big Advantage
what is it almost plus one apparently
but uh yeah it just feels like lack of
control now and like you say if yeah uh
if Yan gets this this kind of
opportunity to strike opportunity to
calculate his way out of trouble he will
take it he will seize it at the margin
for error is far lower now for doing
yeah a little bit disappointed because I
made this whole big speech about how
ding is you know with his Superior
understanding he is capable of playing
before allowing E4 and you know now he
didn't back me up there I feel so I was
betrayed by ding but uh that said I I
understand that okay this is also very
tempting and it's a very concrete
approach and I think he got seduced by
something here and now he probably
realized that what he planned is not so
so simple so he's taking a moment there
um because of course it's before
business it was um it was not so obvious
but I did think that uh since he was
going for this line I thought that okay
he maybe he has figured it out but it
seems as yes like like every human he
just got seduced by some
something concrete there on the road
instead of
going for the Strategic strategic
solution
and a few moments ago in the feature
chat Anish we did see a uh kind of
interesting statement uh ding's problem
maybe overthinking and Yan's problem
underthinking do you think uh that's a
good summary yeah for sure there are two
types of players there are those who
overthink and that those who are under
think that's clear
um
and sometimes you are you know it
happens to you both happens to you like
in my case I think in my case it's
mostly overthinking in a
yeah mostly for me it's overthinking but
uh sometimes you try to speed up and
then you understand so this it can
happen again of course is really usually
uh overthinking is usually not his issue
and Dink yes of course he he does
overthink things a lot for sure yeah he
sometimes doesn't trust his intuition
very very often when he's in bad shape
in Vikings day tournament where he was
uh not in his best shape
he was not trusting his instincts so
many games even the one against me I
played the game with him and so often it
was clear what the direction
should be and so often he would start
thinking for a long time and make a move
that was clearly not uh on our radar
both of our Radars at all but he just
kept going deeper and deeper and started
to overthink and came up with these
weird moves that were also not very good
so
ding definitely prone to overthinking
when in bad shape and having lost two
games in this match we cannot yet speak
of things good form he has to prove it
still and yeah he might start
overthinking here but let's give him a
benefit of the doubt he has uh still 40
minutes the bar is with him
and let's see what move he will he will
make but we can take a look at the
engine uh lines here to see how they
evaluate oh the engine actually really
likes through K3 and it says it's the
only move to to maintain the advantage
Queen A3 is like a lot less
yeah someone who's prone to overthinking
I do empathize a lot with ding it's one
of those positions you can certainly get
kind of uh too far down that rabbit hole
you can get carried away with
calculation when at some point you just
need to kind of take yourself out of the
position as you say and you should just
say just kind of talk to yourself for K3
only move that kind of even hints an
advantage or keeps the tension keeps the
ambition up everything else feels like
black is uh able to simplify and on the
flip side it's Yan very instinctive is
that just because he's been in great
shape over the last couple of years
great form
playing quickly yeah that's who he is
right like he has also been playing a
lot of bad moves very quickly the game
that he lost here he also played it very
quickly the game the games that he lost
to Carlson in his match where he was uh
you know when he was doing badly in the
second half of that match he was also
playing very fast so it's just how he
plays just plays fast sometimes it's
good sometimes is bad but I guess it's
just his Pace it's just how he always
played and how he always will play I
think we we could try to think along
with dink after Rook A3
which he made fortunately okay he made
uh the best move I think 96 will come I
think it will come quickly
because I saw the computer prefers
Knight C4 but I think that position
looks very unpleasant
oh no actually I C4 quickly okay that's
the first this is a Top Choice I don't
know that 96 maybe something was wrong
with it but to me Knight C6 looked
interesting I don't know maybe I missed
something there
no but it's a Top Choice 94 is a Top
Choice and we get that position we are
by the way calculating Bishop C4 is a
must DC4
Knight B7 is very tempting uh Queen B6
Knight D6 rookie 5 de5 Queen B2 and then
rookie four okay five we get the
position that we were looking at I
likewise chances there a lot I likewise
chances there a lot but uh that said
it's a clarified position
so at some point there will be a
concrete sequence of moves where uh you
make a Movie Maker move it gets kind of
forcing and in the end of that forcing
line either white wins or it will be
draw so it will get very concrete
but I think we are going down that line
I'm very excited to see what's going to
happen there
yeah should we jump in and try to go as
deep as we can try to figure out what's
going on in ding's mind let's bring up
the board and like you say it looks very
forcing I don't see any junctures that's
why I would also we could also just talk
about life for two for two minutes
because I guess that in two minutes
we'll end up in that position on the
board because the moves are absolutely
forced
yeah so how's it going I guess
life is good thanks how are you I'm good
thanks okay so it's Bishop C4 this
before
he's going to take this Pawn surely
he's 37 197 maybe 97 is actually an
alternative actually 97 this is a nice
alternative isn't it
one of these two jumps let's check out
this one we assume we'll see the other
one so uh let's allow that to play out
not nice the bar is like no no it's
horrible Queen C6 yeah I thought it
takes 95 but it doesn't give anything of
course
you just move the queen and whatever
nothing no no of course Knight B7 with
Knight on D6 Pawn E5 potential for E6
like that there is so much you know like
that position I would love it in a Blitz
game with white
like there's so much uh so much
electrical potential there for for white
some E6 H5 you know like so many dirty
tricks are there I would love this uh
with white in the Blitz game I can see
uh some sort of a dirty chip or
somewhere coming from a mile away and I
think black has to be extremely precise
here to avoid that from happening but in
the classical game especially someone
calculating as well as Jan he could
avert the disaster and if there is a
solution he could find it
and I think that's the key objectively
if there's a solution then uh yeah I
think Yan will save this game if not
then as you say it's so easy to fall
into some tricks White's super safe on
the H2 Square no problems ever with the
King and meanwhile Queen and Knight we
know how dangerous those are Everything
feels so loose for black this is
undefended this is going to get hit this
queen where does she go it's really
unclear
um I am wondering about like an end game
uh Queen B1 Queen D3 something like this
if I can get it but
I guess can be rejected by white
maybe this is the best bet
so many uh so many moves came to mind uh
uh I didn't see the end game at first
but it's certainly interesting to
consider I was also thinking about Queen
C1 Rook B8 rugby one idea to try to go
straight for the
you know for the Checkmate which
if if it fails might backfire and that's
it the bar says it doesn't work but I
don't immediately see why it doesn't
work
do you see why it doesn't work
looks interesting doesn't it kind of a
big thing
yeah but it's just one check let's say I
continue pushing okay
I guess I'll trade off here and then I
just need to move my queen to give my
king some breathing space I like Queen
G4 Queen H1 King and in G3 let's say
yeah I just didn't see that queen move
but let's say I maybe somewhere else
three maybe
ah Queen F3 may be even stronger okay
yeah just to attack this piece and G3 is
pretty safe for the white king okay okay
this is a good argument indeed very
often when you do this background
business it's just one check and here is
a good example of that so this is not
good one 23 is an idea another idea I
had is I I wanted to go Queen B6
actually that was my first thought that
I want somehow to dislodge the knight
from D6 and okay I give you the spawn
but at least I
Safeguard my Kings for now and I'm
trying to I'm trying to disconnect your
piece so I can say if you connect C4
maybe I can play Queen C7 trying to tie
your pieces to each other and
make you uh make put you in a very
clumsy position at the cost of a pawn
and now you no longer have e6h5 tricks
now you have to worry about coordination
wow things
start with H5 okay okay okay okay what
is that what is that what is the bar the
bar is okay with it yeah
looks okay yeah not changing things too
much
okay H5 is interesting you you include
H5 and then you want to do the same
I should say it's very comfortable very
good because the pawn on H5 it could
potentially get attacked so let's say
you go Bishop H7
no
I don't know so Knight B7 or what
let's say Knight B7 for example the same
variation we're talking about improved
version
uh so it's an improved version yeah you
claim because of some because of what
exactly some queen of three or
uh somewhere Feels Like An approved
version
let's say the same thing maybe it's not
so different here actually
I didn't know for whom it's an improved
version uh are you sure it's an improved
version for uh for for white because I
got the bishop away from the E6 tactic
H5 Pawn can potentially be exposed
I was guessing I just assumed that Ding
thinks it's an improved for sure we can
assume that the thing is that but also
instead of Bishop H7 maybe I can place
the bishop somewhere like on D3 or
something
wow where it's going to be more stable
yeah and you're saying okay you can take
opponents some variations but like we'll
get active in return yay that's what I'm
hoping for I'm ready to give you the I
don't even see how you take it because I
have some rookie one counter play there
at the end of the line
Bishop D3 looks uh optically like the
best move uh to me but it's a very
concrete position so let's see why the
bar doesn't like Bishop D3 and we are
unable to guess a single move here
because it's so difficult so concrete
and the uh points or like the
disadvantage of each bishop move will be
revealed many many moves later so we
cannot see it uh you know with Horizon
as humans you cannot see uh see it so
far ahead
looks uh
the most sensible to me it is a very
young type of move Bishop very very
visuals are stable there you know it's
it's like defended by the bishop page
seven the problem which page seven is
that I'm afraid somehow of a back rank
now like the background could be an
issue so I'm very worried about that I
don't want Bishop H7 I hate that move
instead if I have to choose yes I think
I planned the bishop on D3 because okay
on C2 it's kind of weird and vague yeah
it's hanging in the air somewhat but on
D3 it's nicely protected by the pawn I
think Bishop D3 will eventually come but
young will of course have to calculate
the consequences of all that
uh we talked about Yan being impulsive
sometimes this is the position here has
to sit and calculate it's so crazy so
many options
yeah it's difficult I was wondering if
you could take this and then go like
Queen E7 or queen C6 yeah but that's
aggf looks very sass but maybe it's
possible actually somewhere Queen tape
and take this Knight but yeah it feels
very shaky
yeah if you take this Pawn there'll be
some check and
white is uh cashing in before black is
ready
is a is it
is it possible to go like 8G FG because
the bar is kind of acting weird so could
I go
Queen somewhere and then trap the knife
sort of wow
here
or with the queen else
I'm trying to come down oh oh oh Queen's
Queen D5 and queen D1
oh one so
Queen d8 sorry 28 ah whoa a niche
in this position
take and this is crazy but I just saw
the barrier that's why I found it of
course I'd never find it should I just
try to make sense of the bar and I and I
try to understand like how does it not
transpose but Jan can do this by the way
this is such a beautiful resource
he's capable for sure oh yeah yeah oh my
God this is a it's actually it's
actually a blunder I think what he did
he actually blundered this
can he still uh can he still somehow
salvages after rookie five Rook takes E5
Queen takes feels wrong no no end game
is bad D Queen d8 maybe here like okay
one
to stop any tracks but now the black
yeah
take
three sorry maybe that's the wolf
in this position yeah instead of rookie
yeah defend them and defend the pawn as
well okay this is uh some damage control
there at least
hmm
still looks oh this is so much better
yeah yeah this one was bad for black
because I take 97 and it looks actually
as bad as ever
this could be one way that Yan might
spot the idea but then reject it anyway
right yeah exactly exactly exactly you
might get briefly excited
but then you see Queen F3 and you think
okay you have even an even worse version
you have to realize as a human
of course players they don't have the
bar
or to C2 oh wow okay okay if that's the
best move then I just take my head uh
tip my head let me just check can we
just check if that's the best move
because I just I just want to see
because this is such a random move I
want to see if this is the best move let
me it feels wrong it's like you say this
bishop is floating in the air now it's
going to be a tactical Target it's going
to be hit with Tempo and some variations
I'm surprised that he played it so
quickly Bishop D3 we weren't refuting
yet okay it's the best uh bishop move
because Bishop D3 is met by B4
but you know the only defense that Jan
had in this position Bishop C2 is kind
of kind of close to Lost
um because Knight B2 rookie five
Queen E5
wow just Queen takes queen b696 queen B2
Rook A5 that position is apparently like
close to winning but the defense young
head is actually a rookie 5 only move
the equal in d8 that we saw and after
Queen F3
Queen D2
wow a g201 king H25
G3 Queen C5 queen of 17 h8 and New York
you've been doing your puzzle rush to
your geometry this is crazy I've been
I've been turning on my engine is what I
what I what I did the engine's been
doing it's uh
day in day out day out here I can tell
you wow
how much did you take for this move by
the way
a couple of minutes I think uh okay he
spent about four or five minutes and he
had uh 58 yeah so this is of course
another case of uh
it's a very bad time management of
course Bayan I mean this is a it's
always the case so when Jan wins like
yesterday it was a wonderful year he was
playing fast and good but he's also
playing fast and that like this is
clearly a moment to think for a very
very long time he has like half an hour
more than ding could have definitely
invested 15 minutes here without a
question 15 minutes for sure maybe even
20 maybe even 25 but uh playing Bishop
C2 quickly when there is this especially
if you see rookie 5D Queen d8 I think he
missed it all together I think he was
only thinking about he owns the battery
5D Queen C6 which is horrible so he was
only thinking about which Square to
choose for the bishop and he actually
chose the best Square
yeah but he missed the resource yeah
that in itself is impressive just uh his
instincts Yan but here we go uh Knight
takes B7 on the board Knight takes B7
now has just been played and uh yeah
yeah I'm getting confirmation he spent
three minutes pretty much on that move
just over three minutes it's too quick
way way way way too quick
I don't mean like let's it has to be
taken in a context I mean let's say if
he has four minutes uh it's it's good
but uh he has 58. if ding had maybe
three minutes on the clock he would you
could justify it by saying that he
didn't want to give ding additional time
but given the circumstances given like
you know the the pot odds as they say
and all the stuff yeah given the amount
of time the blackhead amount of time the
Whitehead the kind of problems that he
has to deal with on the position this is
like a classic case of a very bad time
management and this is nothing new it is
uh it is the flip side of Jan's
strengths and uh in a bad position it
becomes his weakness
yeah as someone who has a lot of
experience with bad time management I'm
actually on the other side of the scale
I spend way too long but I know when my
opponents are bluffing and here it's
clear that Jan I mean you need an hour
here to work out all the different kind
of different uh options here all the
variations to calculate as deeply as you
can and nobody can do it in within three
minutes so actually for ding that's a
confidence boost
he knows that Jan is just kind of
playing on feel here he's not uh not
worked everything out yet so ding
trusting his calculation takes on B7 and
uh some of those variations you showed
an issue it's actually similar to those
lines uh earlier with all the cheapos in
the air all the tactics in the air but
maybe now it is an improved version for
ding it feels like he's going to get
centralized
very quickly with his pieces it seems
this queen E5 is the is the way to go
according to the computer so uh I I was
like looking at De before because I had
this e6i but now rookie 5 Queen E5 now
the end game is completely gone because
if you go Queenie 5 Queen E5 GE uh Rook
B8 Knight D6 Rook B2 Rook A6 F7 Pawn is
very vulnerable so the end game is is
finished let's show that I want to put
maybe yeah let's show that on the board
perhaps very important take C5 here and
uh yeah it's all about this one Pawn
this one detail
and let's move check and this Pawn will
drop
yeah now Hy Bishop G6 is just a
tremendous inclusion here like if the
point if the pawn is an H4 Bishop Point
G6 uh this is still very much defensible
you go to B3 and so on uh but yes uh now
the end game is gone so you go uh rookie
525 can be six or queen B6 first the
young platform six first it will
transpose I play Knight D6
because of this nice trick Queen D68 of
course
yeah
where's the queen so yes it has to take
yeah so take and now um Queen takes is
the move preferred by the engine not
obvious but okay it's preferred by the
engine that you take with the queen and
after Queen B2 I believe it was just
through K5
and uh there is this surprising thread
of Knight to E8 well not not unfindable
of course at all but it's just somewhat
surprising it's not
um
not obvious but uh let's say queen C3
let's say if Queen C3
also there's some Knights isn't that
yeah so let's say can I play here 98
. I don't know why the bar is that yeah
it's 98 just oh the bar is staying all
the way yeah yeah this is winning here
F6 for example just
you know or maybe there's something even
better maybe you flick in a check first
but how can this just uh I will take C8
okay okay so Queen D5 maybe yeah
Queen D5 just keeps it simple oh on
Knight xf6 and queen B7 that's nice
oh wow
check and next move we take the Rook
with a check or comes with tempo
it's no surprise though that the tactics
work out here for whites and can black
defend better here uh against this
threat how was the exchange side because
it didn't seem obvious to me so Queen C3
a 98 rookie8
how how clear is this so why is it so
clear is
why is this winning on the spot there's
no checks so there must be some
mating idea
let's say we take
uh yeah I was hoping today Queen D4 and
I was hoping I have Queen D1 check and
the C pawn and it's some
Queen F7 maybe just protects the h51
yeah defenseless so this is just one
yeah it's just it's just a winning
position because I guess look A8 is a
threat watch this material of course
Queen G6
Jesus this is so pretty wow
I actually didn't even see it yeah wow
this is a shame very easy
okay okay so uh definitely definitely
some juice there for for ding some juicy
stuff there after Knight d65 Queen E5
I guess uh this quid xc3 is the mistake
yeah in if you're looking back at this
analysis that we looked at
either way ding has to play 96 here and
yeah what is the yes I mean what else
what he's by the way taking his time but
what else what else he's the opposite of
Jan in this game he is taking his time
when you think that you don't need to
and yeah not taking when you think you
need to so it's just the opposite it's a
remarkable just different styles Clash
of styles yeah really uh I guess Queen
F3 but it just feels so wrong as soon as
you see you can put your knight on the
G6 Square you go for it right close like
I'm seeing here I just put the engine
lines just uh to see the options I mean
there's not even a sensible alternative
you have to like why is he why is he
spending okay he just wants to double
check that he's winning but he has no
option of course is that a sign of
nerves is it just the fact that he's not
felt in the flow this tournament because
ding on form plays this move in 10
seconds
a little bit of that but also as I
already said yesterday I think that
um he doesn't care about the Jan's time
spending he has his own he has two hours
and he has 40 moves and he is just he's
just passing out his time so he has the
time so he just spends it
um but
well you know
28 minutes
it looks still okay but when it looks
like 20 because you know the Old Clock
okay nowadays they have seconds but I
don't know if you remember back in the
day the old digital clocks they would
show only minutes
until you would go down to 20 min to 20
minutes after 20 minutes they will start
showing seconds
and like that would be a big Panic
moment for me because I would see
seconds and I would be like okay wait
this is uh now it's it's going down you
know
yeah so it was on that generation that
went even seconds on the clock yeah
they're the ones with the analogs yeah
yeah the flag that falls so I played
that as well but uh I think 20 minutes
is the kind of Mark that uh gets you a
little bit nervous that's when you and
he has
okay of course he plays 96. he has uh
still to make some moves so he shouldn't
yeah he shouldn't be thinking forever
luckily he played 96 already he has 27
minutes still enough
and after rookie 5.
I think he will take with the queen
because
[Music]
um
Pawn takes is not so attractive now yeah
and after Queen takes could be Turok K5
it's really on Jan to find the defense
it's very difficult
yeah position
extremely difficult for Yan and again
body language I think he's got the best
poker face ever or he doesn't realize
Jan I'm not sure he's calculated maybe
he just doesn't have this Knight E8 move
on this radar that's an easy one to miss
without it maybe it's far less clear
right
but even if you see Queen in 98 I I
don't think you panic as black like you
think that you have options let's say
um rookie five
Rook 5 will come especially from Janet
will come instantly because there's no
alternative let's jump in maybe uh okay
we'll take C5 on the board yeah you know
as a spectator the thing I like about
Yan is that if the move is only move he
makes it just immediately listen this is
nice this is just there's no you know
there's no dead air on on stream he just
makes that move and okay we get the
action think like
he just you know double checks triple
checks
yeah I've got to say Yan like when I
first met him we were eight years old
European under 10 Championship he played
the whole game against me as if it was
blitz so it's he's true to himself most
of us we get slow with age I get much
slower but uh what was the result uh I
managed to draw but he got the gold
medal I got the silver is that the one
where Magnus got the bronze or not oh
that was a couple of years later
um because there was one where the three
of you were uh or or no those you Magnus
and who was there is Ziana got the gold
like the silver me bronze and then yeah
some other like andrekin I think came
forth
um yeah plenty of strong players this
1990 generation but crazy year crazy
Europe is it 990 like it's an insane
year it's like by far the strongest year
of all the years around it
uh I could go on and on yeah plenty of
2700s but but it's already enough I mean
just to to mention Magnus
exactly 90 as well or yes I think so I'm
joking as well this is absolutely
unbelievable
my year 94 I I think
we did but
I don't know like who else is
in the top from 94 I think nobody is
from 94. there's a few 93 Wesley 92 92 a
couple as well 92 is also a couple I
think Fabi is 92 and then and ding is 92
yes yes yeah but yeah 1990 is just uh
crazy yeah yeah I've already planned if
Yan wins the tournament I'm going to
rehash that uh childhood picture of us
standing next to each other with our
medals just for the social media for the
likes
yeah and you can use this picture for on
many occasions you know if Magnus does
something as well or you always have
this there hey by the way d uh de5 is
very much an option here and uh I have
to say that even though the computer has
everything worked out uh the
calculations you have to do here to
conclude which move is stronger
extremely hard and personally I am an
intuitive player so
um I would take that decision somewhat
intuitively
I don't know I have to say that
something in me likes the D the d e move
like especially without H5 some there's
a part of me that likes this de move
especially I think the Knight on D6 gets
the stable support and the potential for
the E6 brake as well
I have to say I'm guilty of liking d e
but I know that the computer says Queen
E5 is the move the money move and ding
spends a lot of time and he doesn't have
uh that much time left because he has to
make 11 moves in a crazy position and he
cannot think forever he only has 24
minutes left so ding will now go all out
it will be his last big thing an
important big thing and he has to yeah
well he's a calculating kind of player
so he might find the best move but the
calculations are so extremely hard and
the modern computers they see everything
very fast but there are so many
deviations and options after Queen E5
can be two okay five I think black must
have many many candidate moves
and while ding takes this big decision
is 50 50. Queen takes C5 or D take C5 we
will be going to a short break but we
will be back in a few minutes with
further coverage of game six the 2023
fide World Championship
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and it make you more social
foreign
[Music]
puzzles here it's just him yes yes it's
Jazz now we're gonna go but suddenly you
know there's like something there's some
kind of triangle so along the place okay
no okay we're not warning I'm not the
fasted
so here is the first one okay
okay so F2 check yeah a rook A6 F2 png2
check Rook takes G3 Knight H3 King h100
second
yeah I think I have sold this already
like F2 is the answer
um actually I didn't have time to
calculate King takes F2 which looks uh I
mean at the very least I can just take
on D3 and on F1 and I'm much really fat
and and there is also to give to Indian
so it's just Checkmate but of course the
point is after look it doesn't matter
which hook takes an episode then that is
Queen G2
check followed by another three check
and it will case up one Checkmate how
are Rook G1 rupees okay
okay I didn't learn then say currently
blind all right your 10 seconds is up
100 yeah I just got it while I was
singing briefly yeah so it's obviously
off two and then uh Queen G2 Knight E3
and Rook F1
wow okay so you're I mean there's also
Rook uptake sheet to the same thing yeah
yeah I mean Worldcraft takes off to
Queen YouTube tonight usually King H1
and then virtue one or two one Spade but
yeah
okay do you like to play and win or what
yes like to play away
my um thanks
I don't know I didn't find the meat I
saw them
[Music]
I'll make a mover
unfortunately the move is not 92.
yeah same thing I'm gonna go find me F2
Rook takes oh F2 I need that warm-up can
we start again
yeah yeah I need the warmer
um
if it was my it was a game I'll go 92
takes G3 and RC but I think it's it's
just special than our I don't think it's
a mate
yeah no I don't
all dead
um the correct move is actually F2
yeah
and then
oh wow like this
somehow it's an unusual pattern but it's
really cool well exactly
it's so easy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back to game six of
the 2023 fide World Championship we
currently see Yan Napoli in his rest
area potentially been big trouble on the
board as well ding has just played the
sequence of moves we were predicting
computer approved as well and white in
charge right now and uh it is actually
janaponishi's move he's still sitting
there not returning to the board a niche
it feels like he's in big trouble do you
think only now he's realizing the big
threats that uh face him
yeah yeah for sure he realizes the
importance of the moment I don't know if
he um he's an optimistic guy generally
very optimistic player so I don't think
he thinks that he is in trouble yet he
he probably hopes um that there is a
solution but he understands that he has
to think about it very seriously now
this is the moment to think and he is
thinking now on the screen he will take
a bit of time there that he will think
on the board because he understands that
98 is coming
if there is a solution he he will
believe that there is one he is that
kind of guy he it has to be here so he's
taking his time but I really like by the
way I told you about the psychological
20 minute mark I don't know if it's a
coincidence or not but look at ding's
clock it is 20 0 0. it is twenty zero
zero you're a prophet Anish uh and
there's no increment either so he must
have timed it on the spot
that's when the Panic sets in no well I
think it will be crazy to actually time
your move with with the clock like that
but um it's a nice symbolic uh symbolic
mark it used to be big back with the Old
Clock it used to be big because that is
when the seconds started ticking down
now with the clock showing seconds from
the from the first movement from already
it shows seconds even when you have more
than an hour the column has changed of
course it's better this way but now it's
less less impactful less symbolic but
still um he left himself with just
enough time I think 20 minutes for 10
moves in this position might just be
enough and the important thing for him
is that
well he has a very clear idea it's 98.
and um it's a huge threat and actually
the question is how do you stop it I I
see this queen C1 G5 staring at me this
is but this might be a huge panic I
think the end game might be bad but 21
G5 is uh sort of it's a big move
to try and at least trade Queens but
there are potentially uh all kinds of
downsides with that I think I don't know
yet the end games could be lost but
besides Quincy 105 I don't know Queen C3
we discussed already Queen City 98 uh we
didn't see a defense what else how else
do you defend from 98 some Queen B8 but
that's just a very very sad
yeah it's a sad position in general the
nation just before we jump in to analyze
some of these variations we do see
neither player at the board right now uh
it feels like okay this is one of the
rest areas I think this is things rest
area maybe he's just off getting
refreshed now he's returned to the board
and it's actually his opponent in move
and upon is still not returning uh maybe
having missed Rook A5 which wasn't
necessarily obvious White had options
there too
um really powerful play by ding it's got
to be said in this dynamic position and
we do await Jan's return to the board
yeah
sorry sorry yeah yeah no sorry
um I wanted to say that I believe that
um Rook A5 is not of course the move
that he would have missed because this
is just uh the nice remover I guess what
you meant to say is that he probably
missed the 98 threat or he had
understated that because
um that is um
that is a bummer and uh 98 is something
that uh
well there is definitely a question that
you you'll need to answer and I think I
noticed it before I don't know if it's
always the case but I think Yan usually
thinks in a resting area when he has
missed something and on his position is
bad this is what I recall from the two
matches that I have observed in this
this becomes a pattern and I think
um when he is uncomfortable with this
position when he's uncomfortable with
what he had just missed prefers to to
think in his own intimacy and his own
resting area
yeah that was definitely the case in
2021 uh after he lost game six against
Magnus uh his future defeats Whenever
there was a blunder whenever he'd
miscalculated he would often stay away
from the board for a long time and I
think it happened in was it game three
and four as well in this uh in this
match uh he did that a couple of times
after missing things for players and uh
yeah clearly right now he realizes he's
in trouble not sure how to minimize the
damage in here she mentioned some ideas
trying to get the Queens off the board
feels like that has to be part of the
plan it's just whether you rush that
maybe the queen C1 Queen G5 maneuver
still on tap for later on
oh that's a good point yeah after 98 you
can still do Queen's one Queen J5 it's a
good point good point there I'm not even
sure if Knight E8 is um
if that is
a threat or rather response to Queen C3
if you know what I mean
it's in the app but it depends on what
that does right exactly I oh actually
the movie that was staring at me is this
move King H7 I don't know why but it was
it's been staring at me wow
intricate no I I don't know it's
probably horrible but I was just
thinking about it
um that's cunning maybe we can jump into
a boat yeah I remember now what was my
idea my idea was 98 through k2c1 that
was my idea
let's put this on an analysis board yeah
beautiful
again with the geometry here it's a
check and yeah
four is the most thematic Perpetual ever
yeah everybody always looks for that
pattern yeah King H7 I like I think H7 I
love the look of this move
yeah I wasn't uh aware of this move if
it wasn't on my radar I was looking more
at kind of defending this pawn and if 98
uh firstly this was on my radar to check
and come back with the queen but then
also I realized maybe you can go back
this way
I have to say all of these positions
they don't look lost to me I don't know
about you but they all look to me uh
they don't look close to me all of them
so I don't know why the bar is so
excited the bar is excited because the
engines are so strong now when they see
an advantage they basically
they either see a defense
then they show it's a draw or they see a
win and then they show it's kind of a
win so the computers are just uh they
see too far ahead basically the position
is promising for white but I don't feel
that it's winning I King H7 I don't see
a win you should D3 I don't see a win I
just don't see why it's winning and I I
see uh you know limited material
relatively speaking I see the a pawns
still there on the board
um I I don't understand why of course I
see why it's dominating with in the
center and has all sorts of promising
ideas but I think it's very early to
speak of the game being over and the
situation on the clock 2 is not in
Dick's favor so I think after Jan makes
the move it can be visually three
camping H7 I think uh it's far from over
and uh I I think ding has a lot of work
ahead a lot of work ahead here
yeah I completely agree I think Jan now
is realizing there are concrete issues
uh maybe when he saw this position from
afar he thought he could simply capture
this Pawn he's realizing now that's
impossible but still plenty of resources
long term yeah I wonder whether this
deep Pawn might decide the game as well
uh this past D opponent could start
motoring up the board in the next few
moves if Yan can get the Queens off
maybe some elements of safety there but
uh yeah he needs to defend this Pawn
somehow keep his a pawn alive and make
sure he doesn't get checkmated so it's
kind of dual or triple purpose uh next
few moves high stakes for Yan and uh
still not back at the board
yeah but I just don't see uh of course I
understand the Deep one maybe one day
but um
you have to show me the line like I
don't see uh anything wrong with neither
King H7 nor Bishop D3
I don't see why why black is in such
trouble
yeah can you explain me so let's say I
play King of seven okay let's jump back
into the board it's my man it's my man
against someone yeah he called it Anish
on the board now King H7 and uh just to
point out uh White can take this Pawn
but now black I guess has time to take
on C3 simply
says something better
I think citria is probably the one I
take and white suddenly has no threats
this King
safer than it looks at least on H7 on uh
this diagonal protected by the bishop so
Knight takes F7 not too tempting
it was around here that I was thinking
D5 maybe Anish
yeah because Knight F7 just uh to finish
that point uh you're making that half
Knight F7
you won a pawn but you haven't
you haven't gotten closer to my king uh
so quickly
is a good move
feels decent uh at least from a human
point of view going to the seventh rank
what could be more natural oh yes yes I
see the point so I see the point so the
queen on E5 it prevents Queen C1 Queen
F4 idea
the Knight on D6 uh is ready to go to E8
or F5
and so ding is improving is improving uh
The Rook also if you start with King H2
which was another tempting option
you started with King H2 I suspect Queen
C3 was already a serious uh candidate
move
because now 98 is root xc8 there's no
more check
so actually uh Rook C5 is uh
kind of an obvious move in in a way
now a big question I have
the question I have
okay I have a few I have a few that's
the position type of position where
there's hundreds of questions I have a
few so my first question probably is
what about A5 because you let my apron
Like You You released released the
you know release The Rook from A5 versus
blocking now I guess A5 by 4 is too slow
but let's try it so it Rook C7 I think
you got to go for mate right yep
so for me it's now maybe enough to trade
Queens under any circumstances and then
I will push the Apon so what about Queen
C1 Queen G5 here
something I can't really run away from
that exchange no I'm really not worried
that's black here I'm really optimistic
about defensive chances because we will
trade Queens then I'll push my a pawn
then you have to go passive and then
I'll get some I mean take maybe Knight
C4 Knight A3 but well I'm not uh not
concerned I think this I should be
No No it should be should be or should I
be able to okay you have to connect the
passers I understand yeah we have
connected passwords C4 D5 they're gonna
we're gonna go very fast
mm-hmm
okay so I have to be more accurate than
that with black cam yeah maybe in the
car position is there a more useful move
than A5 I'm wondering as well what
sometimes why it's just going to take on
C4
let's go blow up the phone I was
wondering about F6 originally just to
try and destabilize your queen but maybe
this is still a good Square for her six
yes F6 is also a move uh so taking on C3
was bad because of Knight E8 I recollect
is that still the case
it was earlier but now you could now I
can take and take on this for you get
rid of this wonderful version of things
yeah no chance you lose this as black
attack in The Rook some tracks as well
even if the Queens come off if you can
kind of get this Pawn even at the cost
of like Queen side pawns should be a
draw
yeah yeah I mean I'm not sure let's say
if it's impossible to lose out with
black but let's say it's not not the end
of the world either so after Queen City
okay maybe just Rook sephoria for now
just collect my Pawn for free
I have to get out of the way I'll maybe
give a track whoa engine hates this one
yeah but okay let's make moves I mean
okay
attack for free maybe the black queen
needs to find a better square and yeah
what was a better Square something
closer like D2 maybe something closer to
I'm not sure why this is such a big
change but I think maybe after Rook C7
maybe it's something to do with F6
and then Queen D1 Queen H5
if I take then and queen just six yeah
yeah now I'll take with the bishop and
then get away
White's got to be careful here of the
past eight point long term
wow so 360 is fine or not because it is
fine not just looks playable Queen takes
C3
let me just take a look at what the ding
me so why was the bar saying that I'll
just take a look one moment uh here on
my um
on my screen I'll just take an engine
just to see because I remember the
computer was saying that white was
winning and I no longer understand uh
why he is
so yeah th7 which is the best move
oh wow
some crazy stuff I imagine this is the
computer's dream where it's all concrete
it's all forcing the stakes are high for
both sides this is some weird engine let
me check another one because this engine
it says Queen E1 let me just try another
engine
[Music]
anyone really
my God they all say 21. so the best move
after K7 was Queen to E1 what the hell
is that move so back in this position
instead of Rook C5 which was played in
the game just to drop back with the
White Queen but yeah just defend just
defend the C3 pawn and collect C4 or F7
just as greedy as that can you can you
imagine
wow such an ugly move to Goku anyone how
can you
can you do that
yeah of course of course he he won Rook
C5 now Queen C3 yeah and uh
well there is uh there is the option of
Knight takes F7
but already why it's uh Advantage here
it's uh it's it's not decisive at all
yeah it's not not the size of if
anything actually it's a very very
Jewish Jan is probably going to escape
in this game actually
that's probably escaping this game
do you think it was influenced by the
clock that last decision Rook C5 because
there were plenty of options I mean
Queenie one we can definitely forgive a
ding for not finding I don't think uh
many Mortals would find that move but
maybe there were other things he could
have considered he played Rook C5 very
quickly
he's kind of just guessing at this point
if he has no time to he cannot afford
anymore
um but you know he was never
he was never that clear-cut anymore I
think his big mistake was on move 23
when he didn't go before because that
position computer has evaluated as kind
of strategically winning
it says it's just winning actually it
gives the advantage of like I don't know
like depending on the engine it's like
last two and this um strategic Advantage
was huge
after this concrete concrete sequence
that he initiated the advantage was no
longer this big and well
he had sort of a winning
like advantage of the queen E1 but
it's really difficult to make that move
and doesn't seem so winning to me
um
and after Rook C5 already yeah instead
of 21 there was no other move Rook C5
was the second best
65 Queen C3 it's already it's already
okay for black so
it seems as though
yeah it seems as though it was never so
easy and uh
I think given the time situation uh
jungle now you know compose himself and
find
to find All the Right Moves and probably
he'll Escape here
slipping away from ding
things problem here as well is that
Queen takes C3 is the first thing black
will calculate Yan's very direct very
concrete and if he sees no issue with
that one and he's just gonna play it
there's nothing else he needs to even
consider
um of course maybe A5 other moves you
mentioned that Anish but Queen takes C3
if it works and it seems to do seems to
do so then she's gonna be on the board
the first move you calculate I mean I
just forgot about it for a second there
but of course as a first move you you
calculate
because now after Queen 1698 do you have
a much better version of black than move
earlier because even then you wanted to
Cycle Exchange but now you can sack The
Exchange in a much better version
because after K8 is no longer a check
he had already stepped out of the check
yeah you know I'm I'm not uh
I'm not uh
optimistic here for for ding after Queen
C3 because a lot of options but all of
them seem very vague to me this Knight
F7 move was uh computers Preferred
Choice maybe it's the best intending
Rook C7 later keeping the tension
actually maybe still asking some
questions yeah maybe Knight of seven is
actually the best move
yeah gotta say though I Want To Praise
Jan just for finding this King H7 move
on the last turn uh I think that one
very difficult decision not easy to kind
of take a timeout in such a wild
position and uh just play a quiet king
move but now all the tactics seem to
or at least the kind of media term
tactics they all seem to favor Black
because there's no checks with Tempo and
uh yeah like you say white will still
find a way to play on I'm pretty sure
ding will play Knight tx7 if he sees
nothing else
it's a very exciting uh position in fact
this is going to be a very exciting uh
phase now as um I I would hope that both
players would have less time for even
more drama whoa not going to take C3 I
think he gave a check instead
the longer I look to the position the
more worried I got because rookie seven
was coming and you didn't have any
checks so I think Nepal uh Jan is going
for the 2g5 idea maybe but I don't know
in which but wait not cannot do it right
now this could be outrageous or F6 okay
F6
Yeah you mentioned that move at some
point didn't show yeah I mean just to
try and kick the queen away obviously
White's Queen has to keep an eye over
this F4 Square uh otherwise that's a G3
yeah G3 is the only Square then
feels that way I'm wondering whether you
can get away with kind of meeting this
check with marching your king up the
board but that feels so wrong
um so brave wow great foolhardy
potentially uh yeah so quenchy three
looks like the most stable keep the king
protected
doesn't feel like a game for black
uh I didn't know
I have uh I have
you know 3007 was there so I got rid of
that I removed my Pawn from F7
and after Rook C7 I have Queen G5 so
after Queen G3 I don't even see your
thread um
I don't see a threat
this is true maybe I'll just take your
ones if you let me
it's not uh getting greedy yeah yeah I
mean I
it's difficult for me to
okay he plays this you have to play
community of course difficult for me to
understand if the bar is um
oh yeah so the bar likes to Industry
it's kind of hard to understand uh
why what is winning is it because we
just collect the C4 Pawn is that why why
it's winning
it's possible Right long term any end
games will be winning for white if you
just take on C4 yes connected passers
simply right and then even end game
is that enough maybe for example A5 uh
let's say Rook C7
Queen G9 to show this yeah let's just
show it because I think it could be real
so if I have Rook C7 in G5 window X G5
and G9 C4 is that winning all right is
that what the computer isn't playing
well I mean it looks close to winning
for me but it went a bit down yeah so
that was not so is A5 uh so is my point
after A5 to go Knight C4 directly
and then after A4
I don't go to C7 oh midnight can I go
Knight E number to cut off the yeah but
it's not sure what's the point because
cut this one off uh let's keep going
root G8 but maybe now I just go behind
right
or even some yeah behind or some even
some Knight D5 kind of attacking
business uh Knight can come back in
yeah maybe not defined as well it's
interesting yes sort of a
sort of a slow attack uh second wave
kind of thing and actually yes white
wins a pawn a pawn can be stopped always
with the Rook
okay maybe maybe you know some sometimes
uh some people tend to overestimate
the dangers of the past Pawns
you might tend to overevaluate your a
pawn and uh yeah yeah not an intuitive
decision it felt or it felt wrong
it felt wrong but
I guess Quincy 397 was also looking very
scary I have to admit I have to admit it
was looking scary so yeah the
fortunately for ding he's still in
control here he's still very much in
control and now Jan is also dropping
lower on the clock ding is feeling more
comfortable it's a big deal when you are
in time trouble that the opponent joins
you it's a very big deal because being
in the time trouble alone you probably
know David is a very lonely very lonely
Journey yeah I'm a very lonely man
always in time trouble myself but uh
meanwhile A5 on the board an ish we're
heading straight down that line we
showed but I don't know like is ding
going to go for the end game or not
because the end game is also reasonably
tempting isn't it like 9493 I okay I
hate the look of it but if I get a
knight on A3 and then I go C4 D5
start marching down the board with my
two pawns it's possible but of course
Knight C4 is the is the money move of
course you don't want to trade Queens
you you want to keep um you know you
want to keep it uh keep it all in
reserve and you want to somehow be
fearless and not be terrified by the a
pawn marching down because it's not so
fast the airport is still not so fast
Big Show is here for ding Rook 7 is a
risk 3 option Knight C4 93 is the more
ambitious one I think knowing ding style
and uh his match situation and c493 will
come
yeah and we've talked about ding
dropping a bit low on the clock he still
only has six moves though to make to
move 40 where he does get an extra hour
so six Moves In what is it 17 minutes
should be fine and here would be a good
moment to spend maybe five to ten of
those minutes actually uh because it is
hearing the the instincts of the time
travel person 10 minutes here uh
spending more than half the time
this is a critical moment no no David
David this is not how it's done please
to be fair I Rely a lot on increments
and uh in the world championship they
don't have that luxury at the moment so
maybe that's something that's optimistic
but you were right I forgot to look at
uh the move counter it's already moved
34 I didn't realize that uh in this move
35 now for dink I didn't realize how
close we got the last few moves at some
point the sequence was very long and
forcing remember with uh the moment he
went Rook B3 then actually like the next
like
almost 10 moves were almost forced so he
got a lot of moves in there and now ding
indeed should spend time yeah I think
five minutes is okay okay if you want 10
I give you 10 but there might be more
decisions to make uh in the next five
moves this one is the key yeah and I
think intuitively and like everything
screams for Knight C4 instead of rules
seven I mean uh honestly looks seven
Knight c493 that's a little bit
miserable
um
it's safe and it's an attempt to play
for a win without risk but it's it's a
little bit miserable it and of course
the Instinct of ding is to go Knight C4
Knight E3 block the queen then go for
the attack which is seven and try to try
to go for the kill and only go for the
end game once once it's completely
winning
yeah this black queen really living a
miserable life actually
um I can't blame Jan for going for this
too much but again it feels a bit like
he's rushing these decisions A5 as well
there were options
it is 20th time but um I I think he just
just the squeeze the three Knight F7
position I mean I can imagine he didn't
like it uh
you know it was also not it was not
solving the problems like Quincy 398 was
about because the Knight F7 it kept it
kept the initiative going and I think
Jan didn't like it he saw some issues
with that Rook C7 was coming he wanted
to uh protect this F Pawn with a tempo
send the queen back to G3 and he thought
okay Rook 7 I have Queen G5 always so I
can sort of understand where he's coming
from
understandable mistake but he had not
not uh not the computer Precision by Jan
uh in this game so far definitely not
yeah and that's the key question will
dingshire computer Precision Knight
takes C4 is obvious maybe we can jump
into a board here but Knight E3 you do
have to weigh up right uh
maybe that move is the tricky one
Rook C7 I think Rook G8 is not as
tempting as Queen G5 is it
and yeah the Queens off you should
yeah yeah
Dingus uh
it's difficult I could see I could
easily see a strong player go for this
end game I could easily see that happen
even the end game by the way will still
uh it will still be you know it just to
be a question maybe you will win the end
game I don't think the end game is easy
for black Knight A3 and push the 45 and
okay uh I don't know I don't see like uh
if you ask me I would think I have good
winning chances because if you go Bishop
B3 you don't have the counter play with
the Rook if you go Bishop D3 with ideal
V8 after I got C4 Rook B8 2K7 and I
don't see how you
um necessarily
sorry maybe I just go with D5 Ruby 3d6
as well just more direct
it's a question it's a question yeah
maybe bishop F5 but well at some point
the C Pawn will join Knight B5 Rook a 7
will happen yes uh both options very
tempting looks a seven as well seven as
well but I think Knight C4 started with
Knight C4 uh
that is nice I I hope for things that he
will you will find that
or choose that rather there's nothing to
find it's just something to choose
and I guess you can do it from another
move order but uh just less accurate
potentially uh C7 you might as well keep
your operational options open here by
taking on C4 first uh with this idea of
dropping back with the Knight which we
also thought was strong
you might think that you avoid Rook J to
Rook C7 first because after Rook system
Jade they're 98 wins on the spot
nice you might think that you avoid that
um but wait why am I not winning on the
spot
King h
H
whoa this looks over any shy agree uh
Queen G5 just to show um there is a fork
here and a six uh using the pin so
where's the defense maybe you're
basically just ridiculous wow
ridiculous this looks like it should be
Checkmate but maybe Knight C4 Knight
c494 anyway Knight C4 is the move this
is the move on the board yes anyhow the
move basically however you think about
it that C4 was the move how much time
did you spend
it was a long thing
yeah
seven minutes since we did in between he
he followed he listened to commentators
and he decided to go to take the mid
Middle Road I recommend five you said
ten he took seven
yeah it's good a good decision there by
ding
E4 will come instantly I think A4 is uh
is a must young will return from the
rest area play for instantly and then it
will be a big choice
Rook C7 so human so human to go to C7 93
even more ambitious both moves are very
close to winning
matter of style matter of taste
and as you predicted A4 immediately from
Yan that pawn was actually attacked as
well so you might as well push it and
hope for the best our spawns are there
to be pushed but uh more importantly
Checkmate I think he's gonna play Knight
E3 ding just it feels like he's in that
type of mood we haven't seen that many
end games this tournament uh this match
so far
just like he was better for kill that's
bad let's bet that's better I'll take
rookie seven what are we batting a niche
you know everything my house my uh you
know I don't want your house I just want
that Magnus mug I'll trade it for the
year okay okay okay
I'm not gonna put my Magnus mag on on uh
on the base here for for some I did not
gonna jeopardize you know
he's nervous though you're nervous when
you play Rook C7 you're nervous when you
don't play Rook C7
yeah
it's true but you also never seen end
games when you're facing an apron when
you only have a night nights are so bad
against aprons I've seen those go wrong
plenty of times and he's about to make a
move okay my mug is on the landing don't
don't you go 93 my Mark isn't blind if
he doesn't go neither then okay it's uh
it's all good yeah 96 or something at 96
or something then it's uh nobody has
gets my mug
my B6 is very likely also by the way 96.
wow
sorry Anish
thing that with the computer Precision
smelling smelling blood smelling blood
and going for the kill going for the
throat wow it just feels like his mood
this this whole match is like do or die
it's Checkmate or be checkmated and uh
yeah he learned yesterday the queen of
night versus the queen of Bishop it's a
bit of a kind of mirror image where Jan
out played him with the Knight versus
bishop and he's gonna do the same
on my behalf of course I'm not gonna
give you my mug I mean that I'm not I'm
not that stupid but I'm going to get you
one ordered
I'm not gonna clone you honey sure
but uh yeah meanwhile Rick C7 a huge
threat now
yeah
what's he gonna play I don't really see
any tempting moves for black other than
pushing the a pawn but that looked
miserable the variations we were showing
that
I was thinking uh I was thinking about a
move I don't think it's uh no it's it's
losing but I thought of Rook A7
preventing The Rook C7 move but then
even the worse I got onto the eighth
ring I go on V8 through C8
so you cannot control the seventh rank
you have to prioritize the eighth rank
is even worse so yes I guess you push
the a pawn
I guess
rest area again
just feels like he doesn't want to come
back to the board when he knows he's in
trouble
when he knows he's missed something or
misevaluated something do you think he
missed 93 surely that was on Jan's radar
well I think from afar he misasses a
bunch of things and I think he
underestimated 93 as well
I think from afar he he pinned his hopes
on the a pawn and he thought as long as
he's not mated and the a pawn goes up
the board it's all okay but now I think
he realized that the a pawn is not as
strong as he had hoped for
uh it's it's very limited what what uh
what it has accomplished and the threats
the second wave of the attack is very
strong so Rook C7 followed by Knight D5
that is still a massive massive attack
and he was somehow hoping probably that
as long as he can defend with Rook Jade
after 7 he will be sort of okay and I
can understand that you can understand
the stinging process but yes there's
sometimes yes it's just gets a little
bit deeper than um
and then the first instinct sense of
course yes it's still not clear I mean
it's still not so clear to me I don't
think it's all over so let's say A3 or
X7 Rook G8 yep let's jump into a board
let's put uh this line on A3 very
forcing defending checkmate
hey is this completely done so
um
so Knight do you do you go for Knight D5
already or are you just controlling my
Pawn First which one I'm very passive in
these yeah I mean they both look good I
would just at least look at this one
first because now I have a threat of
just capturing on C2 and picking up this
Pawn yeah maybe I need to move my bishop
and I cannot move it to beat B3 because
of Knight F5
when all the G7 square is also falling
so I need to move my Bishop somewhere to
like E4 Maybe
and that's a good Square stopping me
jumping forward this way
you have many options of course you have
many tempting options here I even wonder
about a simple move like Queen to D6 if
you're not just picking up the a pawn
but okay maybe you want to preserve the
C Pawn because maybe this is not as much
as I as I can get maybe I can also play
like Queen F4 first between G for a lot
of different moves
yeah it feels like it should be winning
right this black queen is so far
detached from the action so offside
right now and uh yeah the other move you
mentioned Denise more direct
maybe suiting things uh mood more for
the game as Knight D5
is more direct for sure no 95 is the is
the money move so then you just have to
calculate King h8 only move
and then you can probably calculate
Knight E7 I suspect
it's the most tempting yep then you have
to move the Rook let's say to E8
and now
um now we have to finish it
there must be a way yeah 95 Queen G5 is
not immediately over so here you have to
finish it
how do we finish this game I mean I'm
again tempted to just come back yeah
yeah I think that's maybe how you do it
Maybe
yeah and uh Jan does return to the board
oh yes excellent excellent
mm-hmm
because after Queen G5 I can just take
on G5 and I can even uh
I can attractive yeah
some fighting chances but well there's
many moves there I think even T56 maybe
or just retracting the Knight back like
to to some Square it's also looking very
good let's see let's see okay so Bishop
B1 first he wants to keep the bishop
away from a trade potentially
and now Rook C7 Knight D5 it looks so
good it's even like it's up we're up a
Tempo yeah it's not even a good
defensive attempt just up a tempo
yeah it feels odd from Jan Bishop B1 no
it's just wasting wasting is the same
line we looked at but just with the a
pawn only one step further away now this
is just hopeless now Knight D5 you have
to play King h8 then Knight E7 you have
to play rookie eight
or some other Rook move uh I don't I
don't know I don't see what what his
defensive attempt is looks totally
hopeless to me
yeah it feels like he's just almost
given up uh body language he's still at
the board things got 10 minutes left but
yeah it feels like he essentially did
admission of defeat right Manish and
only three moves to make for ding uh
only three moves to make for Ding and
ten minutes while dink uh completely in
control uh completing control here and
suddenly suddenly we are in a position
where ding just has to convert it and it
it does look uh it is not yet that the
game is over but it is becoming already
obvious to both the players I think that
white is winning
completely winning most likely and you
just have to put the finishing touches
here it's not uh that the game is
decided of course there is still a lot
of tension there uh in the air but um I
think it's quite clear you're up a pawn
a pawn is still so far away from
queening the country play is too slow
there should be a decisive blow here 95
97 is I suspect how it begins this is
just too tempting of a start and that
will already be move 39 only one move
before time travel
everything is uh everything is here
going uh ding's way
yeah ding doing his thing and 95 looks
like the best move I guess the idea
behind Bishop B1 was to prevent the
white Rook from moving uh for now
because the C3 Pawn
is on priest but yeah just move the
Knight out the way looks straightforward
yeah does it feel like a repeat of
yesterday just with colors reversed just
with rolls reversed uh like yesterday
yeah
I read the I read someone uh I read
someone mention that interesting fact
that so far all the games have been
one-sided but not for not for the same
player which is very unusual
they've always been one-sided but Jan
want to answer the games and ding one to
one-sided games which is very weird
because you have one-sided game if you
are much better you would think but I
think that comes because they're very
asymmetric and there of equal strength
with every asymmetic strength so certain
positions doing a superior to Indian
certain positions yarn is superior to
think and so like you get this weird
one-sided games by two different players
and yeah well maybe also they are both
not uh defending the best way so far but
they are attacking in the best way um
that's possible that's possible I had I
once had you know when I was a kid I had
some I had an interesting uh small
training camp with vishi Island but we
play trading games and all the games
were the same in a sense that one side
would win
very easily as well
and it would be different sometimes he
would beat miss out beat him and I
remember also kasim John was there he
was also he knows he was like this guy
so guys it's so weird here somehow
you're both not fighting it's just like
one wins on the other wins whatever
weird it happens sometimes it happens
um and in this match it's it's so far
it's the theme of the match uh but it
makes it only I mean it's it makes it uh
very interesting because
it's such a close match the game sir so
not close yeah
that's a pretty cool experience Anish
pretty cool name drop as well just
hanging out with Anna and the training
camp playing some training games uh but
uh
I only had a few such opportunities of
course it was uh it was not the first
one so I was already a little older the
first camp with Anand I can tell you
what happened I played a lot of training
games with him and I like like a lot
like we can say like 50 games and I won
two and I wrote uh both of them down so
the entire Camp so it was kind of kind
of funny
uh chess players we don't remember
losses we remember all the victories
though and uh meanwhile I did talking in
victories I did see in the featured chat
just a few moments ago uh I think from
Bigfoot that this is the first time the
London system has been played in a world
championship and it looks like it's on
course to have a 100 record
impressive the opening choice just
inspired actually from doing in
hindsight yeah how low have we Fallen as
you know it's a game
hello have you fallen the new low
reached in the world championship
matches guys though I must say I am
surprised because I think Magnus did a
bunch of trash uh in his world
championship matches like the trumpovsky
he played also the cola d493 E3 and
Magnus could have definitely played
London at some point uh during his uh
Dynasty or whatever Dandy Ranch calls it
it could have definitely thrown in a
London or two there but he never did for
some reason but yeah he'll he's gonna
regret this somehow I think what Magnus
always expected he expected his
opponents to be better prepared than
they were because we see here Jan Jan is
very well prepared somehow ding keeps
getting opportunities and I think
um Magnus wasn't he was playing all
sorts of weird ideas in all these
matches
he was too much in his own head probably
trying to be too deep because just
playing the London just playing you know
like C3 Bishop out Castle rookie one
Knight the center just make normal moves
and you just can win the game I mean no
need so
no needs to do anything strange just
play normal chess and the win Magnus was
also capable yeah that's what he does in
tournaments but uh yeah clearly players
do adopt their strategy for World
Championship matches for better or worse
sometimes you just need to do what you
know best and okay Yan meanwhile playing
A3 pushing the apron
yeah no I think uh indeed Magnus was
mostly shining in the tournaments
because probably he expected some
special prep from uh from players in the
match but it seems that their prep is
just as ordinary as during a normal
tournament because at the end of the day
what more can you do when you play a
tournament you also try your best you
just have to try your best okay you have
a bit more time
to the end of the day you cannot
memorize everything and you cannot
understand everything and yeah
we should probably talk a little bit
about the game as well because uh things
are moving somewhat
and uh it's it is now being stern is
moved 40 how much time does he have it's
five minutes okay it's a lot of time for
one move
and he is ready to ready for action so I
think Knight is it 97 uh what are his
options is it 97 that's at least the
most obvious move uh maybe because we've
pointed it out before it's stuck in my
head now that move looks like ding is
about to play
and there we go to Knight E7 indeed but
but what yeah so how do you finish uh
after same question as we had before so
how do we finish it off after uh Rook
moves just to be to be clear yeah and
it's we'll look for that finish in a
moment at least it's worth pointing out
we have reached move 40 ding will get an
extra hour on his clock so he's left the
board understandably he'll go in refresh
and he's got that luxury an extra hour
to figure out how to win this I think by
now he will know that he's winning he's
up a Pawn Yeah Pawn is under lock and
key
um this white Rook is going to keep it
nicely uh in check and yeah should we
jump into a border Niche yeah I think
it's uh it's it's obviously completely
winning and I think it's uh there are
multiple ways to do it but uh I'm just
looking for the one that forces the
resignation you know I'm looking for a
clean finish so
oh yeah oh yeah I think I maybe see what
it I know so I was going to
or yes yeah so oh yeah Queen C7
wow uh threatening Knight G6 if rookie
seven which was what I was worried about
maybe I have Queen B8
keep the clearance diagonal
preventing any checks by keeping the
White Queen here and you take and if
assuming you're in time here with
anything just yeah yeah
trade queens and go back yeah this is
the worst case is enough
yeah and just in time and I pushed my
own points as well yeah yeah
but after rookie 837 maybe the defense
is King H7 yeah it's the only move maybe
which I didn't see initially
yeah this is not the forcing uh one I I
missed King H7 from afar okay so I don't
know C7
let's see let's see how else to finish
off okay any night move is uh
the candidate
yeah
Knight F5 is Queen G5
uh Knight G6
8G okay this is not not maybe winning on
the spot although it's very very good
yeah I'm not seeing the win immediately
either
what about Knight F5 uh
-huh I'll drop back with the queen to
defend
yeah probably even trade Queens I should
I think I should because stage five is
hanging
at night the
night
96 93
Knight D6
attacking me oh yeah yeah okay seven
Knight of seven H six this is mate
wow it's nice actually yeah a trap there
yeah
mate next move guaranteed almost lost
and uh I think that I think that's
that's a win I'm not sure this is the
win but it's a win it's good enough
maybe maybe I messed up here Niche maybe
after Queen takes Queen I should take
with the F Pawn in hindsight just to
prevent you mating me in that way
but that position is anyway lost so
let's say I go Knight D6 rookie seven
Knight F7
sorry not okay eight okay eight nine
seven is King Jr okay check is much more
accurate uh King H7 Knight F7 G6 I can
take on A3 and just win it slowly
I suspect but maybe or HG yeah it can
even go HG first
because if you take with the bishop
after Knight E5 your Bishop doesn't
support the a pawn
yeah I think this is the most I think
this is the most straightforward human
way to win this is enough so rookie 8
maybe is the losing losing one maybe you
can try some other move in a starting
position but I don't think they they'll
help you they look even worse maybe Rook
f8 or
you don't have many you pretty much have
a choice of three here for Yan he's uh
thinking over his move 40 with 22
minutes left
yeah it looks like all all roads lead to
Rome at this point
and that's one of many as you say Anish
and ding has an hour to work out whether
he can go for checkmate whether he can
pick up the A3 Pawn
yeah even better uh situation amazing
amazing match seriously this is a
completely uh completely remarkable what
we are seeing I haven't seen something
like this in a long time I mean I've uh
looked I've followed all World
Championship matches starting from
kramnik topalov I think I followed them
all uh kind of live
and okay Carmen topalov was an insane
match though it had some crazy starts
with kramnik losing a game then
then I think not showing up to the
second one getting a loss as well so he
started down two games
and then he somehow came back with two
wins and took it to tie break
that was that I think the one that comes
close is anantopalov that was a very
Tipsy trivia anatopalov had a couple of
uh and then bouncing back once then to
pile of bouncing back as well and then
losing in the final round so I think
yeah we had some ups and downs in the
world championship match history and the
original chapter match history but the
more recent ones of Magnus they were
much more cagey much more slower just so
many draws were always there
yeah unfortunately the matches they
didn't bring the best out of Magnus
until the last of championship match
where after he managed to somehow open
the floodgates in game six and he
started collecting win a win after win
but um a lot of other Magnus matches
they were just uh very slow and we got
used to the slow pace well here okay
it's completely different just a win
after win by both players and after this
game we'll have a equal score again
remarkable stuff
yeah and you mentioned those two words
game six it always seems to be game six
I'm just remembering uh yeah Fisher
against basket game six uh yeah Magnus
striking of course game six last time
Splendor between this neutral blunder
between Anand and Carlson game 6 in
2014.
just always seems to be this game and
Yan must be sick of the sight of this
one he wants to get to the second half
at this point
yeah and okay you tried Rook of fate
uh his idea is that after Knight F5
Queen G5 he no longer loses uh
to this
no longer loses the tempo to the 96 move
so it makes a lot of sense
can I
can I try something different here is my
question
well can I try to finish it off on the
spot
I'm wondering Anish whether we can go
for that variation you mentioned earlier
Queen C7 because now The Rook on f8 will
be hanging after Knight G6 in many lines
but it anyway goes to G8 though right
kh7 96.80 problem
I'm looking outside the smooth Queen
at all good but it's a move
with a very clear thread
yeah also this Pawn will be under Fire
from Queen D6 oh actually I didn't
realize that's actually a double attack
potentially there yeah maybe Queen D6 is
the cleanest here
looks like there are many good options
here for dingleren he's away from the
board so is Yanda ponieshi we have
reached move 40 both players have been
given an extra hour on the clock and we
think this one is going to be a win for
white but let's take a few minutes break
and we will be back with a conclusion of
game six of the 2023 World Championship
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
and review games from the world's
greatest players with live commentary
cloud analysis opening Explorer and
table bases find all the key event
information including schedules prizes
results news reports player bios tie
breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
accessible.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book club
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
presentation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
God he just blocked yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over as the Chess
World Turns to Kazakhstan the Magnus
Carlson Dynasty is set to close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in wait
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon him
and Jana palmistry once again holds a
one-point lead in the 2023 world
championship match what an incredible
bounce back
dingley Wren knows firsthand what the
end of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame Don is just gonna
smash through on the king side ding
didn't have a good day this is all over
and what a game I have to save
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
hello and welcome back to chess.com's
coverage of the fide World Championship
2023 we're currently in game six we see
dingleren poised to strike back to level
the scores at 3-3 by winning his second
white game in a row
he's been playing a great game so far
I'm here with Grandmaster Anish Geary
the world number six we've been taking
you through the action and Anish any
chance now for an upset any chance for
Jan to save this or do you think it's
got it in the back
well everything is going against uh
against Jan right now I think the fact
that we've just reached move forward is
very unfortunate as well very bad news
things got an hour to figure this out
there are plenty of good moves here
available of course it'll always happen
because let's not get ourselves the
position is not decided yet I mean I
I know the many commentators when they
see the evaluation bar they start to
talk about how quickly winning
opposition is and I notice a lot of
people actually do it and spend time
myself do it but if you actually look at
the position without uh bar without the
computer and okay it's still of course
uh it's still not finished the a pawn is
extremely far Advanced so you have to
find the finishing blow
you have to still be accurate there are
a lot of options but none of them appear
to win on the spot at least not not
immediately so it's possible of course
it's possible but uh you cannot imagine
a better situation for Ding A winning
position more than one way to win and a
lot of time on the clock just after the
time control so no I don't think it's
like them
yeah he is investing that time wisely
it's a good moment to kind of reset to
freshen up at move 40. uh he spent
around 10 minutes now I think Ding and
uh yeah he's suddenly calculating right
now
plenty of forcing lines you mentioned
though that uh maybe no knockout blow uh
Anish after calculating for a bit can
ding take a kind of take his foot off
the pedal and find maybe a more prosaic
way to win
the one one move that I think uh is the
lazy way to play and um
I'm not sure this is the right way to go
I think this is how you often uh start
messing up these positions but one
laziest way to place Knight g6568g I
really like that um I that approach
because with that you first of all
establish the spawn of G6 which is there
forever black will forever have the back
rank issue the bishop once gone from B1
will not be able to support the a-pon so
I I'm sure that after 968g white is
winning
uh I don't know how easy it will be to
convert because you'll have to deal with
some
some kind of an H5 21 uh Perpetual check
ideas so let's say black could play
Queen D1 you will have to deal with that
somehow
um also you have to keep an eye on the
G6 spawn a little bit you have to keep
an eye on the a pawn it's not trivial
but it should be winning but I don't
think that this is what you want to do I
think this is what you do if you don't
see anything better but I suspect that
there are some better moves
um some better ways to to play
um that okay that move Queen D6 was sort
of um I sort of mentioned I guess that
was the most natural that I had seen
but I don't know I don't think it was
one of the engine moves um
maybe maybe there's something uh wrong
with maybe Rook E8 is uh
the response because King age is also
working H7 Maybe kh7
I have some Knight D5 maybe should we
jump into a board and try and figure out
what we would do in ding shoes yeah
because nowadays you know the bar is so
ruthless that uh people very often
accommodators very often stop analyzing
kind of early because they think okay
it's probably winning and then they get
probably shocked when the players make
mistakes but uh to be to be very honest
I think the position is very analyzable
it's still very far from from clear so
26 is uh we saw the bar just took a
small hit there
I thinking H7 is Knight D5
I think that looks winning so I I would
I don't see another move than rookie 8
because I'm presenting Knight G6 check
and then I'll pick up the Rook with a
check either with a knight or with a
queen so all the bishop moves are losing
all the queen moves are losing I have
very little options I can either remove
my rook and the only square is E8 or
move the King which is King H7 so I
think there are just two moves there
maybe rookie 8 is the best uh
but then
there's a small truck here as well okay
seven yeah okay seven
and suddenly the whole Advantage
disappears uh this is Perpetual check
the white king can never Escape if you
go forward you get uh mated even
Outback this repetition that we've seen
a few times now
and uh yeah the king gets chased so yeah
some traps some ghosts so easy yes yes
the Trap but too easy somebody mentioned
here so uh in chat uh
a ding is uh gonna take half an hour I'm
not not be shocked if he does won't be
shocked because this could be the last
big thing that he should take
you know when I uh at some point
switched on the uh lines of the engine
just to see the options that Andrew
suggests the first line completely
shocked me you know it was I think it
was oh now I get it all right but it
actually it's a very difficult move to
make it wins on the spot oh it wins on
the spot actually I'm gonna get it Rook
B7 wins on the spot wow if you gave me
20 guesses in this show David it's
because it's because you didn't see the
point like I also didn't get it at all
but then if you think about it for for
one second you see immediately it's on
repeat it's just it's you can resign
it's over
yeah but it's all over it feels so
counter-intuitive to let this Pawn
Advance uh to just take your eye off it
for a moment but like you said yeah no
exactly yeah exactly you you think the
Rook is well placed there and you don't
see The Rook B8 idea because the idea is
of course a one Rook of fate and queen
queen G6
let's show this uh A1 you make a new
Queen
check
and checkmate
beautiful stuff but I also I'm pretty
sure I would have never seen that move
but because also I have many
Alternatives so I think I would never
find that would be it Ruby seven I mean
unless I think forever
and I just by elimination but it's just
not the I like exactly it's so
counterintuitive to remove the roof from
behind the a pawn but once I see the
move so once I said said it out loud
Rook B7 I immediately realize of course
that it's winning on the spot
it's just it's just over immediately
like it's just there's nothing to talk
about yeah
earlier in the broadcast you did say if
you break through in the eight rank is
even better than the seventh rank so
makes sense from that point of view but
yeah incredibly hard visually uh it
looks like you're focusing on this point
and you actually want to background
Checkmate you know if you think
I probably maybe can find such like
there are some players you know what it
depends on so it depends on your search
algorithm because everybody has a
certain search because you cannot of
course calculate all the moves in chess
because um the tree of the variation is
too wide the question is uh how
um how do you select your move for
example I know that Magnus he has a very
narrow search so that's why it's very
quickly reaching a very good conclusion
because he dismisses a lot of bad moves
on every each turn and I notice it
because that's also why he often misses
um some some tactics because he's just
dismissing moves and this allows him to
go extremely deep and uh he he can
afford to do this as well because he has
an incredible evaluation
function so he is able to evaluate
positions extremely fast and I think a
player like Magnus or Kaku is this way
he might just never consider Rook B7 but
there are players that
calculates Much More Much More broadly
in particular Fabiano has an extremely
wide search he is looking at a lot of
options
for both sides and the first few moves
and I'm pretty sure if you give half an
hour to Fabi he will spot through B7
simply because it enters his radar
because he considers more moves it
considers more moves basically but it
doesn't mean that you come to a better
conclusion it means you waste much more
time and you spend time in the wrong
direction very often he just spends much
and I don't know what kind of calculator
ding is
um
but he could he could find Rook B7 but
again there are other ways to win as
well that are much more intuitive so not
sure yes fascinating the point you make
I also attended a lecture recently where
Magnus was uh basically saying he goes
on Instinct and he calculates deeply
from those variations uh also one of the
speakers at that lecture was uh Ramesh
and he was encouraging these young
Indian players to do a scan of the boat
it's like okay do you have any good
moves with your Rook here it doesn't
look like you do but if you ask yourself
that question uh maybe you find Rook B7
Knight Queen likewise and okay D5 played
by ding he immediately leaves the board
and there we do see a question mark from
the uh very harsh chess.com trainer
there it looks like a good move to me
why not push him
the thing is that of course the
algorithm and it's understandable
um
it's probably possible to fine tune
actually as well at chess.com
um when the eval drops from let's say
plus five to plus three
you can probably change the algorithm
that it doesn't show the move as a
mistake because essentially both are
winning at the same time sometimes you
know a plus three is less than a plus
five so D5 compared to Rook B7 is a
mistake but okay position is still
winning and after uh thinking for longer
the bar um
the bar went higher up it's plus four
now so yeah even the question mark will
disappeared no D5 is a much more human
attempt to win so the question I have is
so A2 is uh probably queued up
so after A2 what is the idea or is the
idea simply that black doesn't have a
next move
maybe that's the idea you can get the
point to A2 but no further uh one square
yeah does he just want to go D6 or not
is that simply the idea just push the
Deep on as far as possible
possibly
um I don't see any reply to that for
black the black queen needs to be sorry
my Iris the black queen needs to be back
in time to G5 so the queen can't move
the bishop has to protect the pawn if it
lands on A2 like it's a bit stuck like
it's frozen so it makes a lot of sense
that white can uh push the pawn forward
I'm liking it and Jan is back at the
board and clearly in calculation mode I
don't think he would have expected this
somehow it's not as forcing as all the
other options we were looking at so he
needs some time to react sometimes I
think
and Anish how do you think you'll react
yeah I think A2 uh I think A2 at the end
of the day I don't see how other moves
contribute to to anything okay he can
try he can try to go Queen D1 but yeah I
think he's reaching for the a pawn I
guess 21 and Technical H5 but then
probably F3 just does the job
now 8082 of course he goes A2 yeah and
now I just want to I want to establish
so is it
is it uh ah okay okay okay
No in fact the computer suggests
the D6 is not the way
okay something even better yeah Queen C7
I'm just trying to understand Queen C7
if what has changed so if
King h
it's complicated an issue it is a little
bit complicated but
uh I do feel a little ding maybe could
have found a cleaner way to do this this
feels messy now at least with the black
porn on A2
seven I just I think he probably sees
sees it because I didn't need to go D5
so we he probably sees it I don't see it
just yet Quincy seven I think I think H7
and then if Knight F5
yeah let's jump in Finish
I'm just trying to remember what what
changed so why did we play D5
what has changed you want to break
through here but black has multiple risk
Queen G5 I guess
doesn't look like much has changed here
oh yeah but Knight G7 I thought maybe
Knight G7 was the idea but uh
maybe Knight G7 what is the defense here
our Queen E5 is where Queen if I had
taken 96 yeah
it's crazy stuff maybe I just moved my
king and what do you do next yeah
this was always the resource yeah forget
about it no sorry so yes yes that's why
I didn't so Kenshin was a defense we H7
okay so this bar is all the way up so
let's let's try to find it what's going
on here
night where uh Knight G6 is Rook G8 yeah
let's put that on the board threatening
chat mate you have to defend
I don't see a knockout blow here
but the bar suggests that there is one
what is this Pawn doing okay what's it
changed yeah
so confusing some some Checkmate I'd oh
okay wait wait there is a um
is it
you know what is the fun fun fact is
that if I had my Rook on A8 the queen
xj7 would be Checkmate that was that's
just a fun fact
and uh meanwhile we see ding come back
to the board very excitedly uh he was
away from a moment or two I think in his
rest area just trying to calculate this
variation that we're looking at it yeah
it bugs me that I don't see it and I
really want to find it
I really want to find it
but uh
I I hope for him that he found it that's
what matters I don't have to find it now
though I I do what I do want to
does disturb me
critical moment maybe he'll show us
before we can work it out a niche it
looks like he's not because I really
like the challenge I really like the
challenge but I don't know do you see it
you don't see it also it's not easy no
it's not easy I mean what is it it's
like you said earlier everything looks
winning but it's an illusion uh you
still have to be a bit careful a bit
accurate black does have some resources
yeah it's not at all uh no no it's not
alone it's really not obvious
I'm struggling here gotta say what
position we were stuck on Queen C7 the
first move
he sees it he sees it you know this is
the remarkable part he sees it you think
so he looks very excited yeah yeah he's
excited and he's broke something pretty
even
oh it's so disturbing I don't see it
look he sees it you see he's going for
it what is it that he's going for what
is the finish of the king h78 what is
the finishing touch
wow he is a genius thing so he's uh
gonna show us something clever he's he's
and it's it's his moment to to shine
so he he is a modern engineers and he
should do it
I'm also being told a niche that this
was the only winning well the only
directly winning move everything else
the advantage would uh have been greatly
diminished
25 him
the idea to
but I I just don't know what this is
this is beautiful this is something I
see some different patterns but I don't
see the
the order in which I can do it
I'm struggling as well King H7 yeah he's
deep on involved I don't think the Deep
one is involved and I don't know why D5
had to be played
wait he's close to mating that Anish the
king oh wow okay we have to show this
sir on the board I think I've come up
with the idea let's uh jump in both
players are away right now I think he
wants to sacrifice his Queen and D5 does
contribute here so okay there's a
discover check we were assuming uh King
H7 let's bring up the analysis board
while Yan returns and now Knight G6 we
were saying rookie Anish Queen F7
I'm going to take this
and Checkmate you oh
that's weird look at this I'm not uh
this is not my strength checkmates I'm
gonna start something I'm bad at
checkmates
check many patterns there is a video
online also where a bunch of top players
don't check it's it's just not my
strength it's just very difficult oh
this is beautiful wow and so this is why
the default D5 push contributes you
cover the E6 Square cover the Escape
Square he saw this what was it five six
moves in advance
young seed
he doesn't he plays King H7 oh I just
did the courses D5 takes away the E6
Square oh wow that's a beautiful
finisher
yeah it just seems well amazing wow
that's so beautiful
I must say shout out to the featured
chat I saw that uh people were hinting
that it was a beautiful finish and
that's the only way you can stumble
across this unless you're doing and
you're unless you're a genius I would
never have found this either no it
reminds me of something like uh
it reminds me of something but it's it's
a very difficult position to solve I I'm
sure it's difficult
I'm sure it's a very difficult one to
solve because uh yeah these ideas are of
course Queen takes j8 is is a theme that
we all know with opponent F7 which I
could find but the one where the king
comes comes to F7 and nonetheless gets
mated that's a very unusual theme this
is very rare really remarkable that he
from all the options he found this one
this is really tough it's much harder
than to me than the Ruby 7 rupee this is
really like
okay but yeah maybe it's uh
it's amazing yeah well he found it it's
uh incredible stuff
shout out to shout out to ding for
finding this beautiful chat mating
pattern shout out to the feature chat
for giving us a clue on that Queen
you're like a rapper you know shout out
a rap song
also the 40 000 people watching uh over
in twitch uh what a moment this is about
to be we're about to see one of the most
beautiful finishes to a world
championship game I think in history and
ish everything but it's every day I mean
the guys they're just like the final
positions are so beautiful every time
it's just incredible it's seriously it's
it's disturbing how beautiful the stuff
is it's like I mean it's just
aesthetically I was I said it yesterday
but it just keeps happening this is just
so beautiful from a chess point of view
it's just so incredibly satisfying this
checkmate
wow it's so satisfying it's so hard also
to see that seriously it's uh how do you
spot D5 with the idea Queen Seven how do
you even spot this it's completely
Beyond me how you can see it from from
afar you must be told genius yeah and I
guess the way he found D5 first was
spotting this whole tactic realizing the
black king was running and then kind of
tracing us back to square one yeah
actually seven he's so crazy seven then
he saw Chris is 17 H7 96 through he suck
with F7 yeah he saw Queen takes G8
doesn't work because of uh king of seven
King E6 and then he worked his way back
yeah that's probably what must but it's
seriously sick it's a sick stuff it's
sick stuff wow and Jan I don't think Jan
saw it coming either but he certainly
sees it coming now he's realized what's
happening a queen sacrifice is
guaranteed at this point to deliver
checkmates black can only postpone the
inevitable and
yeah I'm curious if Jan had seen it
coming from like a move or two before
I'm just curious because uh
there are a few checkmates you know I
have a collection there are a few I
should actually make collection but I've
I've missed also some there are a few
checkmates uh which are like very short
like one two three move checkmates like
that but they are extremely hard
and um it's really interesting that some
top players see them
and some don't and I think it has to do
with how many uh
how many Checkmate patterns you solve
the circuit like let's say we also like
a thousand or two thousand ten thousand
but some have sold hundred thousand and
some that are exceptional like Mommy Dr
of Duda uh some of issue Polgar some who
have solved the crazy amount of puzzles
as kids they are more exceptional at um
check many patterns while some other top
players
um
that they are they have other strengths
and they are less alert to this uh to
this magic many patterns but the addings
found a very beautiful one and it also
he set it up from so from afar that D5
already sets it up it's really really
insane he set it up four moves ago he's
about to execute it and uh Anish the
Eternal question as a chess player do
you resign now knowing yeah you're about
to get checkmated or do you let it play
out on the board if you're young
no but uh I know that you British guys
especially you you are all about
Checkmate on the boards but no I'm uh
I'm team young I resign no I don't want
to see it and uh just as you say it
there Nish Jan has resigned you called
it no beautiful chat mate on the board
but still a beautiful game Beautiful
Finish from Ding and the scores are
level at three three what a day it's
been
no but I'm still uh I still need to
recover from the final Checkmate it's so
beautiful
wow and we will recap that uh that
Checkmate the incoming Checkmate for the
viewers after this yeah ding though he's
gonna be buzzing he's got to be high now
momentum swinging in this match day
after day you would have predicted this
well at this point you could have
predicted it already it's already it was
it was it was already it was already a
thing
um ding has come back once at this point
you could predict them predictable and
uh but yeah it's really unusual stuff
and
you know again like yesterday it was Jan
who looked like the best player in the
world and think looked very miserable in
the entire game and today is the
opposite this is a ding it's it's a ding
show today
and wow like uh day in day out like the
players they are able to bring their
best
um but they alternate that's very
unusual and uh yeah a remarkable match
so far with uh in a lot a lot is a lot
more is left a lot left in store for us
as we are still approaching the first
half finish of the first half of the
match
yeah it's only game six and uh still
eight rounds to go and this one
definitely feels like the players are
inspiring each other uh to show their
best striking back uh kind of
continuously at this point and Anish
shall we go and recap this uh this
incredible game from ding right from
move one we're hoping for a press
conference a bit later on but
um yeah while the players have left the
stage let's go back to the beginning and
uh it was the London system the infamous
London system
yeah and the yarn shows this very simple
setup a healthy setup with the 5c D4 at
that point instead of 564 there are a
lot of different options the there's a
big line with Queen B6 Tech V2 for
example right here and Knight H5 as well
but he went for the simplest of all cded
Bishop F5
and now dink went for the very
unassuming very quiet City like Bishop
B5 followed by C4 is much more
principled but that's what the other has
prepared mainly that's where he went
deep these complications he has figured
them out instead ding went for the very
unassuming C3 E6 Bishop B5 allowing
black to develop comfortably he didn't
want much just wanted to get the post
structure just wanted to play this
position maybe he realized that Jana is
not comfortable in the Casbah structure
so curios you could get it to Colors
reversed and uh just rookie one and
already here y'all maybe made a few
inaccuracies H6 allows 95 instead of 27
dropping back uh out of the Knight X E5
detects E5 Fork was maybe more clever H6
is the most natural move to keep the
bishop on F5 not allow another short but
now 95 came with the tempo Bishop C6
already kind of annoying as above the BC
before the C6 Square will be a c61 will
be um
uh weakness so Jan logically went for 97
and after A4 I think here again the
sequence he went for this was a big big
positional mistake he went A6 followed
by 97 allowing ding to
fix this spawn structure now after takes
takes an A5 the Knight is heading to C5
and uh the queen side pawns are blocked
in such way that you cannot see the
night out ever and this was already very
unpleasant and uh yeah it was already
determined let's say who is going to
press here and uh then around move 22
something interesting happened after Jan
tried to drum off some counter play with
E5 move 22.
uh yeah here ding went for a concrete
sequence with Rook B3 instead and this
play Just
went somewhat out of control the thing
was always in control but it went sort
of uh uh it started to get very forced
and uh Jan had some chances according to
computer and I think the decisive moment
was around move 32 after Rook C5
computer was claiming that there is a
defense after Queen xc3 Knight takes F7
still possible to defend there but what
Yan did it was not good because after
Queen C1 and F6 he kept the F Pawn but
ding simply captured the C pawn and um
the iPhone look like it's gonna drum up
a lot of counter play and it actually
reached A2 in the game but it reached no
further
as uh dink found
amazing net
in the end and a very beautiful one
there were multiple ways to to win but
this is the rugby someone very beautiful
by the way very beautiful too but he's a
sexually much harder and much much
prettier in my opinion this D5 followed
by Princess 7 and then Queen F7 setting
up quidx G8 amazing and to see the
players already ready for the press
conference
yeah beautiful finish from Ding and uh
hopefully we can hear what he has to say
about his victory
let's see if we can get that press
conference up and uh yeah
here we go in with the place
welcome everyone at the press conference
of round six we had one more decisive
result today dinglieren won with white
pieces and the result is three to three
the first question
to ding how comfortable was it for you
to play London's system today in the
game and
if this was your home preparation how
many moves
was the home preparation
well
actually today I was very
I'm not sure which opening to play and
in the last time I decided to go for
this London system also the line
occurred in the game he played Bishop if
I was out of my preparation so I just
try to keep the position as
not so fast as and give some possibility
to play for a win and I think it turned
out to be quite well
right thank you and the uh the question
to Yan if you have expected that today
the London system might be might be
happen and also on the second question
right away what was the most challenging
for you for this game
um well yeah I just among among other
things of course I expected like London
in one of the games so it happened
uh yeah but I guess I played uh one of
my worst games ever
uh so I mean like near every move was I
mean yeah it's hard to believe I think
every move was bad and even then I get
the second chance out of this awful
position
I think it was like pretty much equal at
some point if I would play Bishop
different instead of Bishop C2 uh yeah
even that was yeah unfortunate so yeah
but they
right if I make and ask what was the uh
the the inaccuracy that all this started
I mean uh it's oh I mean my whole game
can't like
uh all contains of inaccuracies yeah
okay
all right
and the question to think you have spent
quite a lot of time today on the board
instead of the rest area have you found
your comfort zone right now on the table
yeah I spent most of my time after he
played E5 Rook B3 yeah this was
not not my plan not according to my plan
maybe I should have played before
instead of Rook B3
so
before the position was nearly one side
I was the one who person and he didn't
have much counter play but after E5
after Knight J5 suddenly he has
a lot of counter play
yes
so maybe I'll pray I didn't play it so
well in the middle of the
game spots
yeah I'm very happy to find Rook A5
might be the critical move
yeah in general and
I feel I was in very good trip there
during that whole game
and I it I would not so influenced by
yesterday's rules
I will now give the floor to the press
for the questions I'm sure you guys have
a lot of questions for today's game
please Mike
thanks my climberchess.com my question
is for mostly for Grand Master John
napomnishi I'd like to ask you about a
very specific moment in the game after
H5 there was this very strange resource
Rook takes E5 D takes E5 Queen back to
d8 I'm wondering if you saw this at all
with ideas of Queen D1 and queen H5 or
did you see it and reject it because of
the response Queen F3 uh no I didn't see
but I somehow thought at that moment
that
uh
I mean the position is not as like
as bad or something I think like once
again with the bishop D fremo for
something it's quite uh
uh I mean definitely it's worse but it's
surely holdable
uh yeah but uh perhaps after Bishop C2
let's
um yeah
that's not so easy but uh yeah I guess
uh this is some nice trick like takes a
28 but um yeah it's like it's on
Checkers you shouldn't uh I mean you're
not forced to capture on G6
okay thank you
thank you next question please
can I ask a Russian yes of course you
can ask in Russian
um
my question is for Ian uh if we forgot
the result the result you you've had
today so do you have an impression that
you are taking part in one of the most
spectacular uh chess events over the
past 10 to 15 years
answer is
ask me this question and not some other
day
please fair enough uh do we have more
questions uh the the photographer from
here is blocking my side so I cannot see
the journalist okay yeah go ahead Mike
if you can please just a little bit
yeah my clientress.com my question is
for Grand Master Dean Lauren at the end
of the game Anish was seeing all these
checkmates on the chest.com broadcast
and he said that they it was disturbing
how beautiful it was he was
complimenting you and then he said that
you're a total genius for these ideas do
you agree that your game today was
genius level
yeah
actually yesterday I saw Hillary mark
he believes I I will tie the match
despite the I was lost yesterday so
thanks for his uh his confidence yeah
today
is the game itself I feel very very
pleased with uh with ideas many ideas
occurs over the world
yeah in the end yes this D5 followed by
Queen C7 also I was very happy to find
thank you next question launcher please
my question is for Ian yesterday you
achieved something really fantastic when
in the fifth game just after looking the
fourth one you just said that today's
game is the worst you have ever played
do you have a logical explanation for
that I mean maybe too much
self-confidence or something like this
thank you for the question but I think I
just played really poorly
and yeah in some way it was uh I don't
know like a mirror from yesterday's game
yeah like the same material like
and the same patterns but uh
yeah I guess the tension is high
so yeah sometimes you're going to
perform as your best thank you thank you
very much do we have more questions from
press
yeah please come my clan chess.com
question for Grandmaster ding Loren
after yesterday's game you said you were
very sad or upset I'm not holding you
correctly but you were down were you
able to change that mentality yesterday
or did it only change when you started
playing your game today
well the story was that uh today I was
struggling to find which opening to play
just before starting of the game
I have many choices
and in the end I decided to play this
London system because
actually I was not so afraid of
uh it's hard to say I just want to play
something else more familiar with it's
I try to stay calm after this this tough
rules first and this opening I think
should might still pretty well
it's like it's kind of reversed
cards part structure in the third game
so I can say it went very well
okay thank you
thank you very much now it's time for
the Twitter segment we're bringing the
questions from Twitter so when everyone
who cannot travel here can anyway ask
the questions and we will bring it and
please just say
my name is Jesse February my first
question is for Yan
do you find that your patience runs low
in certain situations why is that so
sorry again do you find that your
patience runs low in certain situations
why is that
no I don't think it's anything about
patience it's yeah
it's about like
a lot of bad movies made like
in one particular game
uh so I guess that's not the case
thank you next question or
three what were you calculating
uh the point behind this right so what
were you calculating during that time
uh Rook history
I saw Bishop G6 in episode 23 instead of
Rook H3 5.9 PS3 he had Knight C6 and if
I go Queen G3 I don't want to change the
currency immediately I want to keep the
possibilities
so it turns out the Rook history is a
very useful way to move just improve my
position a little bit more
all right thank you and the last
question I have is for both players
from Emil
why do you think there are more decisive
games in this match then will
Championship matches in the past uh
we'll go with Jan to answer this first
now
ask me this question another day
sorry ask me these questions like some
another day
we'll keep that
what about you ding
I guess the reason is maybe we are not
that that professional than Magnus
you're very honest
okay oh do we have more questions from
press
we have please Mario go ahead
hello Maria from just.com the question
is for both players uh so far this is
the most decisive match equal to karpov
versus carcinoy in 1981. why do you
think we are seeing so many more
decisive games in this match than
previous ones is is it your styles of
playing or your attitude towards chess
or something else or maybe start with
yeah
are we still keeping this question for
the next rounds Yan or you would like to
answer
okay and sting no it's uh just the same
question in the previous one
yeah but maybe something about your
Styles
um do you think it might affect
maybe until now there are not so many
computer line happens during opening
phrase
so early division from Theory
yeah sometimes we divide from this long
fourth line
well anyway we appreciate that because
it makes the match very exciting thank
you
thank you do we have more questions from
the Press
please go ahead go ahead and ask right
now because this will be one last
question and meanwhile I would like to
just make a small announcement as
yesterday there was a question about the
coverage
of the match in China
uh so um I have an information that the
the live broadcast in China are on
jejung satellite channel and CCTV
channels which covers the entire country
and also
um a lot of new sort news sources are
covering the event including seeing what
news which provides reports every day I
apologize for my Chinese
uh words I just tried my best to
announce if someone is interested for
these links please approach me I can
share the links of the news in China and
if we have one last question please
yep commentary team
for ding
um like at which point did you see the
movie Rook A5 like after Queen takes B2
like when did you get that planned well
just in the end like after Queen takes
B2 happened and then you start after I
take on E5 the first I was thinking
about at least Nancy foreign
take and this end game is not so easy to
win so in the end
uh so I guess the other move doesn't
work so in the end I found the last
chance
thank you um
um I I think we don't have any more
questions from press I don't have also
more questions and we can conclude
today's press conference tomorrow is a
day off and I wish the players to have a
nice rest day and we will meet each
other the other day thank you very much
[Applause]
and here we have the scoreboard after
game six the score now is 3-3 after ding
equalized with a fantastic Victory today
what a game it was finishing it off in
style as well momentum ding you would
think Anish what are your conclusions
after watching that press conference
yeah momentum or not it's hard to say at
this point uh maybe if we are looking
for a pattern or even that is float but
if you're looking for a pattern maybe
the player that plays with the white
pieces has the momentum at this point
because the last three wins were were by
the players with the white pieces so if
anything maybe the next game momentum is
with Yan I'm confused I don't know this
anymore I think uh the match is very
unusual uh the development of it is also
not what we have seen before and uh just
the illustrating blows trading
brilliances and today yeah I think just
um saw a lot of incredible lines and we
had seen at the press conference as well
he had just a very deep understanding of
this game
yeah it was interesting at the press
conference firstly that Ding uh watches
the broadcast shout out he was quoting
you there Anish but uh also that Jan
described it as one of the worst games
he's ever played do you think it's just
the kind of post game uh kind of haze
there or uh is it genuinely gonna affect
his confidence
I don't think it will impact his
confidence very much he's extremely
confident but I do think of course he
realized he made a lot of mistakes in
the opening
I'm not sure if uh
yeah if what what caused it I think I
think they came from the fact that he
you know he's not familiar with his
structure so I don't think that they
they came out of the blue but he
certainly I think what happened is that
he realized that you know point point a
he was having a good position and the
point B it was lost and he realized
between point a and point B he must have
played horrible chess I'm not sure he um
yeah he he knew exactly how it happened
uh and that is also why the choice of
ding was so so good and the sting
mentioned as well here it was fully
aware that uh the reverse Carlsbad
position could suit him better than than
Jan and credit to him although I have to
say I was really surprised to hear how
um how open he was about
how do I even put it like he mentioned
that he mentioned that he didn't know
what to play and then last moment he
decided to play the London and after
Bishop F5 already he was out of book and
he just somehow it sounded all like I
don't know like I'm looking for a good
word but the word is like a maturistic
you know like in a way like uh
normally you would expect that you know
there's like a team and like for months
he is making plans he knows he has seven
white games seven black games or seven
different plans for white he would
prepare everything but maybe he what he
means is that he had a lot of things
ready for the match and this was one of
the things that he chose uh and you know
I mean he says that he was out of book
after Bishop F5 but he played the
position so well and so fast
I don't know he must have studied
similar positions
somehow like if you look at the game uh
it looks as you know the player showed
deep understanding and he did and it was
a great game while he listened to the
press conference it sounds like uh you
know I came uh I saw nothing and I
conquered I mean this cannot be like
that yeah
it's refreshing his honesty though it's
very relatable as well I know a lot of
players a lot of the viewers at home we
kind of turn up at the board without a
game plan we kind of act on the Fly and
we freestyle a bit but uh ding pulled it
off and Anish this was game six let's
look ahead still plenty more action to
come over the coming days
and tomorrow of course of course is a
rest day the players need time to
recuperate recover and we will be back
on Tuesday with game seven it's a
one-off before another rest day and of
course same time same place but what do
you think uh Anish Gary
it's been a pleasure and uh commentating
with you what are your main takeaways
from the day and what are you looking
forward to most after the rest day
now think of the pleasure is mine and uh
well I think that what we had seen so
far is that uh there's nobody's uh you
know is is down in the match uh both Jan
and ding they're able to bounce back
with Incredible chess so it's it's by
now becoming extremely unpredictable and
it's it's no longer possible to
uh to see and understand the flow of
this match is is just a total chaos I
think an interesting uh thing perhaps we
could touch upon because we see the
schedule here and I just wanted to point
out the reason for this one game uh
surrounded by tourist this at first I
was very confused but I think I
understood the point so the reason is
that um they want that not always after
the rest day a player has the same color
because it would give it give an
advantage uh to one of the Players let's
say if he prefers to have more time for
preparing with the white pieces give the
advantage for that player but if they
what they did before is to uh reverse
that they would swap the colors but that
would then give the advantage once again
to one of the players because that
player would have two games in a row of
the same color so what they did is by
creating an XRS day they reverse that
around without having uh players play to
a game with the same color so they they
did this whole operation for this that
means that we have a lot of rest days
and if that game will be drawn
there will be sort of a little moment of
Peace in between the match
um but I have I really wouldn't bet on a
draw I think the both players are being
so aggressive with the white pieces they
come up with such ambitious game plans
not necessarily going for a big
Advantage but avoiding Force forcing
lines which is what ding mentioned
because the forcing lines these are the
ones that often can lead to a Droid both
players know them they're just going for
this positional fights which are very
ambitious and uh well I wouldn't bet on
the draw anymore and uh game seven is
going to be a big one just like every
game so far and I'm looking forward to
immensely you have a certainly method
behind the madness with the schedule and
uh Anish Gary Grandmaster world number
six it's been a pleasure I think you'll
be back after the rest day right
yes I have the plans to commentate a
couple more games for me and uh I hope
you know the then people will find good
replacement in my good colleague Fabiana
Corona who I'm a big fan of and I'll be
of you know following his commentary
with pleasure as well this was also an
honor for me to commentate with you with
uh also with Daniel nardiski and yeah
really really fortunate and happy to be
commentating on this remarkable it's
about remarkable occasion but I will
certainly I'm certainly intending to be
back after the rest day and so will the
players and uh David in terms of your uh
your commentating Journey this year are
you uh are you doing more days with us
or unfortunately not uh this was my
final day in the commentary booth for
this world championship match but I'm
gonna be watching you I'm going to be
watching from afar and enjoying all the
drama of course but uh on that note as
we do head into the rest day we leave
you with the best moments of game six
I've been David Howe Anish Gary and
thank you for joining us everyone
thank you David
I think it's a disaster for black
already this could get incredibly
unpleasant rookie 2 is computer best and
nepo I think
smells it I think he is um
he's he's done here thing has just
resigned the game you stop the clock a
handshake has occurred
and we're off we have the handshake and
okay it is D4 surely he's not going for
the London system or any other things
associated to Knight F3
because he does yes oh no oh no oh no
the London half the viewership is
already lost we're back with some moves
I see a look on your face you're not
liking the developments here in the game
for Ian the pony it's horrible it looks
horrible D5 on the boat either just
strategically horrendous for you this is
ding's kind of game it reminds me of
some of a game I lost today yeah
Indonesia before we dig deeper into H4
we are seeing a lot of uh messages from
the featured chat about your mug is that
Magnus maybe you can show us uh yeah
it's a Magnus with the uem Magnus Magnus
wow
Jan's in his rest area again
just feels like he doesn't want to come
back to the board when he knows he's in
trouble
wow being there with the computer
Precision smelling blood and going for
the kill
Jan has resigned you called it no
beautiful chat mate on the board but
still a beautiful game Beautiful Finish
from Ding and the scores are level
foreign
[Music]